GOOD MORNING
AND MY APOLOGIES FOR US STARTING
JUST A LITTLE BIT LATER THAN
WHAT WE HAD ATTENDED- BUT IT IS
A- OPPORTUNITY TO WELCOME YOU
THIS MORNING. A TO THE JANUARY
TWENTIETH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
SECOND ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING. WE HAVE
SEVENTY FIVE BILLS TO CONSIDER
THIS MORNING AS PART OF OUR
REGULAR ORDER OF HEARINGS.
BEFORE WE BEGIN I HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING NOTES TO COVER.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MCCARTY MULLIN
LUZ RIVAS AND STONE FOR COVERING
VACANCIES ON THE COMMITTEE TODAY
. WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE HEARING BY VISITING THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AT A PRO OR A
P. R. O. DOT ASSEMBLY. DOT CA
DOT GOV PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY
WRITTEN TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO
THE COMIC COMMITTEE IS
CONSIDERED PUBLIC COMMENT AND
MAYBE READ INTO THE RECORD OR
REPRINTED. ALL ARE ENCOURAGED TO
WATCH THE HEARING FROM ITS LIVE
STREAM ON THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE
AT W. W. W. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA.
DOT GOV BACKSLASH TODAY'S EVENTS
. THE HEARING ROOM WILL BE OPEN
FOR ATTENDANCE OF THIS HEARING
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
ATTENDING A HEARING. WILL NEED
TO WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES
WHILE IN THE BUILDING. THE
PUBLIC ALSO MAY ALSO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS HEARING BY PHONE. BY
CALLING AREA CODE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN WITH A CONFIRMATION
CODE OF. ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO THAT NUMBER IS
ALSO LISTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
MAY ALSO PARTICIPATE IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION LOCATED
BESIDE THE NORTH STEPS OF THE
CAPITOL WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC
TO MONITOR THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. FOR UPDATES. COMMENT ON
ANY BILL AN AUTHOR PRESENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE WILL BE LIMITED TO
NO MORE THAN TWO PRINCIPAL
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT AND TO IN
OPPOSITION. ITS PRINCIPAL
WITNESS WILL BE GIVEN TWO
MINUTES TO SPEAK. ALL OTHER
COMMENTS WILL BE LIMITED TO A
STATEMENT OF NAME ORGANIZATION
IF ANY. AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. WE WILL ACCEPT PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY BILL PLACED ON
THE SUSPENSE FILED BY THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. AND FOR WHICH
THE AUTHOR WAVE PRESENTATION
BEFORE THE CLOSE OF THE REGULAR
ORDER HEARING. TESTIMONY ON
THESE BILLS WILL BE LIMITED TO A
STATEMENT OF NAME ORGANIZATION
IF ANY IMPOSITION ON THE BILL
THE COMMITTEE WILL ALLOW NO MORE
THAN TWENTY MINUTES TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF A GIVEN BILL. AND NO
MORE THAN TWENTY MINUTES IN
OPPOSITION. PREFERENCE WILL BE
GIVEN TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO ARE IN THE HEARING ROOM OR
AT THE REMOTE STATION. WE SEEK
TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF ALL WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS SO WE CAN HAVE EFFECTIVE
DELIBERATION AND DECISIONS ON
THE CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA. DO THE COVERT
PANDEMIC WE HAVE LIMITED SPACE
FOR THE PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE SO
WE CAN ENSURE EVERYONE MAINTAINS
SIX SPEED SOCIAL DISTANCE. AS WE
PROCEED WITH THE WITNESSES AND
PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THE
ASSEMBLY HAS RULES TO ENSURE WE
MAINTAIN ORDER. AND RUN AN
EFFICIENT AND FAIR HEARING. WE
APPLY THESE RULES TO ALL PEOPLE
WHO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
PROCEEDINGS. IN ADDITION THIS
YEAR WE WILL BE AGAIN COMPLY
WITH ALL PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS
ARISING OUT OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF HEARING
AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC WITHIN
THE LIMITS OF OUR TIME WE WILL
NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS. OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. WE WILL
NOT ACCEPT DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR
OR BEHAVIOR THAT INCITES OR
THREATENS VIOLENCE EVEN VEILED
THREATS. IF YOU CAME INTO THE
HEARING ROOM TODAY THE SERGEANTS
DIRECTED YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
RULES FOR PUBLIC ATTENDANCE AND
PARTICIPATION. WHICH WERE POSTED
OUTSIDE THE DOOR I ENCOURAGE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WERE
IN ATTENDANCE TO BE AWARE OF AND
OBSERVE THOSE RULES. PLEASE BE
AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS OF THESE
RULES MAY SUBJECT. YOU TO
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. ALL PUBLIC COMMENT
NEEDS TO FOCUS ON THE FISCAL
EFFECTS OF THE BILL UNDER
DISCUSSION. COMMENTS ON OTHER
ISSUES WILL BE RULED OUT OF
ORDER. COMMENTERS TO IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THIS MEETING
WILL. BY MAKING THREATS
INCLUDING BILL THREATS OF
POTENTIAL VIOLENCE WILL BE RULED
OUT OF ORDER AND TREATED AS A
DISRUPTION. NOW WILL MOVE TO
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM. FOR A
MEETING TODAY A LOOK TO OUR A
SECRETARY TO CULTURAL. HOLDEN UP
HERE BIGELOW PRESENT BRAND
CALDERON. THREE OF US DAVIES
EUROPE FONG YOUR APRIL. MCCARTY
I. LEVINE PARK HERE ROBERT RIVAS
. WEBER. MULLIN PRESIDENT. AND
STONE. HAVING TO SELL AS A CORE
MY LIKE TO DISPENSE WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MADAM SECRETARY
WOULD YOU PLEASE READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE A SIX FORTY
NINE. SIX SIXTEEN. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY ONE. SEVEN SIXTY NINE.
THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR. SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT. TEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
NINE SIXTEEN. AND FIFTEEN FIFTY
ONE. MOVE CONSENT. OF A CONSENT
HAS BEEN MOVED BY OUR VICE CHAIR
SECOND DIED BY DOCTOR QUIRK ALSO
IS A MOTION THE SECOND AMOUNT OF
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR HOLDEN.
YES BARTON HIGH BIGELOW AYE
BIGELOW AYE BRAND AYE BRAIN AYE
CALDERON CALDERON I'D
THREE OF US THREE OF US DAVIES
AYE DAVIES AYE FONG AYE FONG AYE
GABRIEL. APRIL I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE LEVINE AYE LEVINE
AYE CORK AYE BURKE AYE
ROBERT RIVAS- ROBERT RIVAS I
WEBER. WEBER AYE MULLIN MULLIN
AYE STONE STONE AYE. CANSECO
LEADERSADOPTED ON UNANIMOUS
CONSENT I'D LIKE TO NOW TAKE UP
TO THE PROPOSED SUSPENSE
CALENDAR- ITEMS- AND DISPENSE
WITH ARKANSAS A SUSPENSE
CALENDAR BROWN OF SECRETARY
WOULD YOU PLEASE READ THE
SUSPENSE GALLAGHER. AB SIX OH
SEVEN AB SIX EIGHT SIX AB VOLVO
SIX AB THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE. AB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX AB THIRTEEN OH
SEVEN AB TWO FORTY THREE AB TWO
FORTY NINE AB THREE TWENTY FOUR
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY TWO. AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY AB NINE THIRTY
THREE. AB TWO TWO SEVEN AB SIX
SEVEN TWO. AB ONE ZERO ZERO ONE
AB NINETY THREE EIGHTY NINE FOUR
THREE AB FOUR FIVE TWO A. B.
TWELVE FORTY NINE AB ONE OH TWO
. AB SIX SEVEN SIX AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN AB TEN NINETY THREE
AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED. AB TEN FOR
AB FORTINO SIX AB. THIRTEEN
FIFTY FIVE SB SIX THIRTY FOUR.
AB TEN FORTY FIVE AB NINE THIRTY
FIVE AB SEVEN OH FOUR. AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN AB TWELVE THIRTY TWO.
CORRECTION ON AB SIX THIRTY FOUR
THAT IS AB SIX THIRTY FIVE.
WHICH ONE. AB FIFTY YOU KNOW TO
AB FIVE FIVE EIGHT AB FOUR EIGHT
FIVE AB THREE FIVE THREE AB
THREE SIX FIVE AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
THREE. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY THREE IS
OFF. AB FOUR ZERO EIGHT AB FIVE
FIVE TWO AB TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
AB SIX EIGHT ONE AB TWO TWO
EIGHT AB FIFTY YOU KNOW FIVE AB
FIFTY EIGHT AB TWO NINE FOUR AB
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN. AB ONE ZERO
SIX SEVEN AB TWELVE FORTY. AB
TWO SEVENTEEN AB THREE TWENTY
ONE. THANK YOU THIS IS BUT IT'S
GALLAGHER IS DEEMED APPROVED- WE
WILL MAIL. MOVED TO BILLS TO BE
PRESENTED TO THE COMMITTEE-
LET'S SEE WE OUR BILL. TO I'M
THE STATE MR PATTERSON IF WE
COULD. OKAY MR PATTERSON IF YOU
WOULD BE WILLING TO ALLOW MR
SHARED WITH THE COMMITTEE A TIME
. MEDICAL TIME ISSUE SO WE WOULD
. HERE AB TWO NINETY FIVE JONES
SAWYER. HAS A DO PASS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MOVED L. AB TWO
NINE FIVE ESTABLISHES A
WORKGROUP OF HIGHER EDUCATION
REPRESENTATIVE PROPERTY STAFF
AND STUDENTS DEVELOP A PROGRAM
PROVIDE COLLEGE FREE COLLEGE TO
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS SINCE THE
MASTER PLAN FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
OUR STATE IS MOVING IN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT DIRECTION CONSIDERING.
CSU TUITION AND FEES HAVE RISEN
1000310060% US CAN YOU SEE
TUITION AND FEES HAVE RISEN
510055% ADDITIONAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE ATTENDANCE SUCH AS
HOUSING AND HOUSING AND FOOD
HAVE RISEN 40% SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE FURTHER ADDING TO
FINANCIAL STRESS OF STUDENT
EXPANDING ACCESS OF EDUCATION IS
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL FOR BEST FOR
CALIFORNIA. THE BACHELOR DEGREE
INCREASES A PERSON'S EARNING
POTENTIAL BY 65% ACCORDING TO
THE U. S. BUREAU OF STATISTICS
ULTIMATELY INCREASING THE
OVERALL TAX CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
STATE IN THE LONG TERM THIS BILL
WITH MINIMAL COST ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DO NOT
COMPEL. IN COMPARISON TO
INVESTING IN UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS INCREASING OVERALL
RETURNS ON INVESTMENT TO THE
STATE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR%
YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU MISTER
JONES SAWYER. ODD YOU DON'T HAVE
AN WITNESSES THAT PERCENT OF
THIS WEEK WE APPRECIATE THAT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF THIS BILL. IS SO PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. SEE
NON- ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS. OF
THE PUBLIC AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
SEE NON. OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON THE
TELEPHONE LINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF AB TWO NINETY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE SAID ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I DO HAVE ONE IN Q.
LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR MEMBER CRYSTAL JOKE ON THE
- THIS IS A THIS IS NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORTING. GOOD
ARMCHAIR PROPOSED ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT OKAY
WILTORD OPPOSITION- SEE IF
THEY'RE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- WHO ARE
SCHEDULED THERE ARE NONE. ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK AGAINST THE BILL
IF SO PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S SEE NINE OF
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE OF
THE PUBLIC AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK AGAINST THE BILL SAYING
NONE. IF BOND WITH CITY OPERATOR
OTHER MEMBERSOF THE PUBLIC ON
THE TELEPHONE LINE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
TO NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
TO SAID ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMON THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. QUESTION
CLICK IN HERE DO WE HAVE AN
ONLINE. WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF THEY'RE
NOT HERE OR IF THEY ARE HERE IF
THERE ARE ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS
. CASINO THIS BILL HAS THE IS
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED- IS
THERE OF. NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WILL TURN TO SECRETARY
FOR THE ROLE. WE WILL COLLEGES
HOW YOU CAN. THE FIRST ONE TO IN
THE BILL IT HAD A POSITIVE
MOTION AND BILL GATES ON THE
VEHICLE. OKAY SO MEASURE GETS
OUT ON TO BE ROLL CALL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MR PATTERSON
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
WE- CALL YOU 42% YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I NEVER
GOT ABOUT HIS OWN YEAH YEAH VERY
MUCH ABOUT BEING HERE AND- AND-
A HEART PARTY WELCOME TO THE NEW
CHAIR. MR HOLDEN. UP IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AUTHORED AB TWENTY NINE
ELEVEN REQUIRING THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
IMPROVE THE FIRE SAFETY OF
EXISTING SUBDIVISIONS THAT DON'T
HAVE A SECONDARY EGRESS ROUTE.
LESS THAN TWO MONTHS AFTER A. B.
TWO NINE ONE ONE WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW. THE DEADLY CAMP FIRE TORE
THROUGH THE CITY OF PARADISE IT
KILLED EIGHTY SIX PEOPLE AND
DESTROYED NEARLY FOURTEEN
THOUSAND HOMES. CAPACITY
PROBLEMS NOTWITHSTANDING
PARADISE DID HAVE FOUR ROUTES TO
GET RESIDENTS OUT OF TOWN IN THE
EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY. WHILE
MANY OTHER COMMUNITIES HAVE ONLY
ONE. HAD THIS BEEN THE CASE IN
PARADISE WE COULD HAVE EXPECTED
THE DEATH TOLL TO HAVE BEEN MUCH
MUCH HIGHER. THIS BILL BEFORE
YOU AB ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR.
PROVIDES A SEQUEL EXEMPTION FOR
PROJECTS RECOMMENDED BY THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION THAT IMPROVE THE FIRE
SAFETY OF EXISTING SUBDIVISIONS.
THAT ARE LOCATED IN HIGH OR VERY
HIGH FIRE. HAZARD ZONES AND WHO
DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH EXIT ROUTES
TO GET RESIDENTS OUT SAFELY. A
PREVIOUS VERSION OF THIS BILL
WAS PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE
BUT IT WAS VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR. HOWEVER THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT NOW MORE THAN EVER
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
INCREASING NUMBER AND SEVERITY
OF FIRES THAT SWEPT ACROSS THE
STATE. EACH YEAR THE CREEK FIRE
THE DIXIE FIRE THE CALIBER FIRE
BEING JUST A FEW. THE BOARD HAS
NOW RELEASED SUBDIVISION REVIEWS
MAKING IT THE PERFECT TIME TO
IMPLEMENT THIS POLICY AND
PROTECT THESE COMMUNITIES BEFORE
IT IS TOO LATE. CALVET
ANTICIPATES THAT THE COSTS FROM
REVIEWING THESE CRITICAL. EDGEX
WILL BE RECOVERED THROUGH LOCAL
PROJECTS SIMILARLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
STATES THAT ALTHOUGH THEY WILL
LIKELY SEE AN INCREASE IN
PERMITS THOSE COSTS WOULD BE
OFFSET BY A FEE REVENUE. AB
ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR IS A COMMON
SENSE SOLUTION TO ENSURE THAT
PROJECTS IN HIGH AND VERY HIGH
SEVERITY ZONES CAN BE COMPLETED
WITH THE URGENCY IDENTIFIED BY
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES. OF CALIFORNIA.
SECONDED MISTER KENNEDY YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING I'M
JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA ARE HERE HE IS
COMPRISED OF THIRTY EIGHT
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO
SPONSOR AB ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR
TODAY. AS MR PATTERSON SAID THIS
BILL EXEMPTS FROM SICK WITH THE
CREATION OF THE IMPORTANT
SECONDARY EGRESS ROUTE PROJECTS
FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES EVALUATED
BY THE BOARD OF FORESTRY THE
THEFT AND- YOU GROWTH NEEDS TO
BE COMPLETED MANY OF THESE
SUBDIVISIONS WERE BUILT LONG AGO
AND HAVE ONLY A SINGLE ROAD FOR
ENTERING AND LEAVING. AB ELEVEN
FIFTY FOUR SIX THE DRAFT FOR THE
RISK ROAD CLOSURE AND CONGESTION
DURING AN EMERGENCY BY
EXPEDITING THE CREATION OF THE
SECONDARY ROUTES RECENT
WILDFIRES A PICNIC COMMANDERS
TOLL IN TERMS OF RESOURCES
COMMUNITIES AND LIVES LAW. AS MR
PATTERSON SAID THE DEADLY
CAMPFIRE THAT DESTROYED MUCH OF
THE TOWN OF PARADISE
DEMONSTRATED THE PRESSING NEED
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AND
EMERGENCY WE'RE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR AB ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR
BECAUSE WILL HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS GET THE SECONDARY
PRESS ROUTE PROJECTS BUILT
FASTER REDUCE COSTS AND AVOID
THE POTENTIAL PARTICULAR THAT
LITIGATION THAT WOULD INCREASE
COSTS AND LIKE FROM POLLUTION.
FURTHERMORE THESE CHANGES COULD
HELP RELIEVE POTENTIAL COST
PRESSURES ON THE STATE TO ASSIST
WITH EVACUATIONS IN THE EVENT OF
AN EMERGENCY FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD. LIKE
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
ONE THIS YEAR. COOPER YEAH
MISTER CHAIR CHRISTMAS CEILIDH
ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT REDWOOD
COMPANY IN MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OR
THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. ON REMOTE- TESTIMONY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK SAYING THAT
WE DO HAVE SOMEONE. UP PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION SUPPORT. HELLO MY
NAME IS MAX MONIA AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL OKAY.
JUMP THE GUN THERE BUT THAT'S
OKAY. I SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS
TOURISTS HERE TO SPEAK ON REMOTE
TESTIMONY IN FAVOR OF THE BILL I
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO THE OPERATOR
OTHER MEMBERS F THE PUBLIC ON
THE TELEPHONE LINE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THAT
SPENDS THE ROLE AT THIS TIME.
RIGHT SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NO COMMENT AT THE TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU I WILL NOW TURN
TO ANY MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE IN
THE CHAMBER THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
. ANY WITNESSES TO JOBS ONE MORE
OVER THE PHONE. ANY WITNESSES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION C. NINE NO
ONE IN THE- IN ROOM TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC AND THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. C. NINE.
ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO. WHITE EIGHTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS MY
APOLOGIES FOR THE LATENESS AND
JUMPING INTO THE QUEUE WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU OKAY WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS. SAY NONE. OF THIS
BILL GETS OUT ON A HE'S ON A
ROLL CALL. CHRISTMAS PATTERSON
THIS CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF MEMBERS APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU- MR LEE. AB FIVE OR A 54%
MISTER CHAIR I HAD REGISTERED A
NO VOTE ON THAT THE- YEAH WE DID
OKAY. AND THEN IT'S WILL RECORD
WE COULDN'T RECOGNIZE MR STONE
AS- AS A NO VOTE THANK YOU YES
THANK YOU. REPUBLICAN. FILLING
OUT THE RECORD TO PICK IT. END
UP WITH MR LIBBY YOU PRESENT-
JUST. A PICKING UP ON MISTER
COMMA WE DO HAVE NOTATIONS FROM
MEMBERS WHO HAVE THEIR POSITIONS
ON VARIOUS BILLS WILL RECONCILE
THOSE AT THE END SO I THINK WAS
STONE FOR HIS- BRINGING THAT TO
OUR ATTENTION BUT GOING FOR
LOTUS RECONCILE AT THE END WILL
RECOGNIZE THAT YOUR POSITION IS
BEEN ESTABLISH. OKAY MR LEE- YOU
HAVE A DO PASS ON AB EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AS DETAILED ANALYSIS
THIS BILL HAS MINOR ACROSS THE
STATE AND RESULT IN TENS O
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS ONLY.
MEDIUM FIVE FOUR SIX RENT
SPECULAR FICTION SPARKLING FIVE
YEARS OF PROPERTY OWNERSHIP
BEFORE THE ALSO THAT CAN BE
INVOKED BY CREATING A FIVE YEAR
HOLDING PERIOD BEFORE THE ALSO
CAN BE INVOKED. ARBIL CONTINUES
RESPECT LONG TERM LANDLORDS WHO
HAVE BEEN IN BUSINESS FOR
DECADES THE BILL BEFORE TODAY'S
A GUARD RAIL AGAINST MORE
FICTIONS AND MORE PEOPLE LOSING
THE ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS AND
NAP ON OUR STREETS. STRICTLY
ASKED FOR I VOTE AND I ALSO HAVE
TWO WITNESSES IF- FOR QUESTIONS
NECESSARY. OKAY THAT WOULD BE
BRIAN A GUSTO YES AND OUR
RETIREMENT COSTS OKAY WE'LL TURN
TO MISTER AUGUSTA FIRST. IN TWO
MINUTES EACH. THANK YOU MISSED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- BRINA
CASTER WITH THE PUBLIC INTEREST
ADVOCATES OUR CLIENTS THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
RENT BOARDS OF BERKELEY AND
SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE JUST BRIEFLY THIS BILL
SIMPLY FACTUALLY THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF ALICE WHICH IS TO
PROVIDE A MECHANISM FOR A RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS TO EXIT TO
RENTAL HOUSING BUSINESS IT WAS
NEVER INTENDED TO ALLOW. AN
INVESTOR TO BUY A RENTAL HOUSING
PROPERTY AND IMMEDIATELY DECLARE
THAT THE BUSINESS THAT WOULD
THEY HAVE JUST ENTERED THAT THEY
WISH TO USE THE ALL STOCK TO
ACCEPT AND DISPLACED TENANTS AND
REMOVE BADLY NEEDED- RENTAL
HOUSING UNITS FROM. THE REAL
HOUSING MARKET AND THE EFFECT OF
THAT HAS BEEN A LOSS NOT ONLY OF
UNITS THERE HOUSING LOW INCOME
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF COLOR BUT
IS HAD TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON THE
OVERALL SUPPLY SO THIS BILL
CLOSES THAT LOOPHOLE HAS NO
IMPACT ON SMALL LANDLORDS AND
THEIR ABILITY TO EXIT THE RENTAL
HOUSING MARKETING CONSISTENCY
WHAT ELSE ACT FOR THAT REASON-
WE ARE TONIGHT ABOUT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU. I MISS
FOX. HE'S MISSED A RAQUEL FOXES
SHE HERE TO ACT AS A WITNESS ON
THIS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
OKAY IF SHE IS NOT THERE WILL
MOVE ON. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL A
NAME FILIATION IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS ROUGH OKAY
ON YOUNG SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
DIVOCK OF BECCLES ELECTED
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
TRANSIT DIRECTOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF AB EIGHT BY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SEE NO
OTHER MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE HEARING ROOM WILL TURN TO
REMOTE STATION HEARING AT THIS
TIME. A WITNESS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. TO STAY. HELLO MY NAME
IS MAXWELL DNIA AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. RIGHT NOT BEING CLEAR.
HELLO MY NAME IS STEPHANIE AND I
AM IMPOSED TO THIS BILL. HI MY
NAME IS ALICIA HERNANDEZ AND I
OPPOSE A. B. FOURTEEN HUNDRED.
THIS NOT THE BILL THIS BEFORE'S
THE BILL BEFORE THEY'RE GOING
THE DO BEFORE HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
MY NAME IS ANDREA HAD STRUM AND
I OPPOSE THIS. OKAY LET'S SEE
LET'S MOVE TO OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINES
OPERATE OR DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES WHO WOULD LIKE
TO. SPEAK REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT. OF FOUR AB EIGHT FIFTY
POORLY. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHT
FIVE FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE IF
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I WANT TO
LINE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS
PREFERRED DOCTOR ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FIFTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU HANK YOU
RIGHT EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING JEREMY. ON THAT
FROM ALL SOME OF PUBLIC ADVOCATE
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
HE- FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
AGAIN YOU'RE ACTUALLY ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FIVE FOUR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU WILL TURN TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. C. NINE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING CHAMBER-
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
REGISTER OPPOSITION. C. NINE
REMOTE HAS PRETTY MUCH COVERED
IT BUT WILL TURN TO THEM AGAIN
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE SAYING
NINE- THEN WE WILL GO TO THE
PUBLIC LINES OPERATOR ARE THERE
ANY IS THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR OPPOSITION- TO. A. B.
EIGHT FIVE FOUR. IF YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB EIGHT FIVE FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES. I
DO HAVE ONE IN Q. BY NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY AS A
PRIMARY MEMBERS. IN I'M SORRY I
DON'T MEAN TO CUT YOU OFF I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT AS A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES- NOT A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN A POSITION.
ANOTHER THE DEMOCRATS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
THE PRIMARY WITNESS- THERE
SHOULD ALSO BE KAREEM TREATY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS OF THE PRIMARY
WITNESS IT'S ALSO IN THE QUEUE.
FOR AT LEAST AT THE PRIMARY OKAY
I HAVE BOTH OF YOU- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND IS A DIFFICULTY
WITH A CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THE ELLIS ACT IS
ABOUT PROTECTING RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNERS AND RECONCILE CITIES YOU
CAN NO LONGER MAINTAIN OUR SMALL
BUILDINGS IT DOES HURT SMALL
OWNERS. BECAUSE THEY NOT CANNOT
SELL THEIR BUILDINGS TO ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO OCCUPY AND THAT
INCLUDES TENANTS WHO WISH TO BUY
THE PROPERTY SOME OWNERS EVEN
TENANTS COME TOGETHER TO BUY
BUILDINGS BECAUSE THAT'S THE
ONLY WAY IN SOME OF THE CITIES
THAT PEOPLE CAN BUY HOUSING. AND
WHILE CA DOES NOT REPRESENT
THESE OWNERS NOR DO WE ENCOURAGE
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS TO SELL
AND GET OUT OF THE BUSINESS
OFTEN IT'S THEIR ONLY SOLUTION
IN RENT CONTROL CITY'S OWNERS
CAN NO LONGER MAINTAIN THE
BUILDING WITH INCREASED TAXES.
SEWER FEES AND OTHER FEES WHILE
FACING A VERY LOW RENTAL RATE-
EVEN MORE SO NOW BECAUSE OF
COVERT SOME OWNERS HAVE LIVED
FOR TWO YEARS WITHOUT RENT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE AN
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT TO PROTECT
TENANTS- IT CREATED RENT CAP LAW
STATE LAW WITH COVETED ALLOWS
TENANTS TO SELF CERTIFY AND
pCLAIM A COVERT HARDSHIP BRING
THEM FROM RENT PAYMENTS
INNOVATIONS. THE LEGISLATURE
PROTECTED THEM EVEN IF THEY AS
WE ARE NOW DISCOVERING MAKE TOO
MUCH MONEY TO QUALIFY FOR RATE
RELIEF AND YET THEY'RE STILL
PAYING NO RENT- AB EIGHT FIVE
FOUR ATTEMPTS TO STRIKE ANOTHER
BLOW YOU'LL TAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR OWNERS TO GET OUT
OF THE BUSINESS WHEN THEY
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO. THE ELLIS
ACT ALREADY PROVIDES TENANTS
WITH EXTENSIVE PROTECTIONS WHICH
WE AGREE TO IN GOOD FAIT AND
WE'RE BACK THE- OWNER MUST GIVE
A ONE YEAR NO AND VERY HIGH LOW
WE- FEES OFTEN IN TERMS OF FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND EVEN AFTER
THIS RETURN SIXTY FIVE. DAY
NOTICE TENET OFTEN A CONTEST
EVICTION WHILE THE CURRENT OWNER
MAY HAVE OWNED THE BUILDING FOR
LONGER THAN FIVE YEARS THE NEXT
OWNER OR EVEN TENANTS WHO WISH
TO BUY AND MOVE. AND WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO DO SO FOR BY YEARS YOU
BELIEVE. THE KERR OWNERS. TO WE
WERE QUESTIONED VOTE- HARM THE
SMALL. WHO LEAST TO THE PANDEMIC
WILL FACE. A BANK TAKEOVER OR
DEFAULT IN TAXES IF YOU LIMIT
THEIR OPTIONS TO SELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU WILL NOW
HEAR FROM A CREAM DRESSING. YES
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CLEAN GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS- HERE TO STAY IN
OPPOSITION AB EIGHT FIFTY FOUR.
AB EIGHT FIFTY FOUR FISCALLY
ARMS STRUGGLING SMALL PROPERTY
OWNERS BY PREVENTING THEM FRO
WITHDRAWING FROM THE RENTAL
HOUSING MARKET IN A TIMELY
FASHION DUE TO ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP. SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS
WERE SENIORS OR INDIVIDUALS OF
COLOR IT'S YOU KNOW. OFTEN PUT
THEIR ONE RENTAL PROPERTY INTO
AN LLC BASED ON THE ADVICE OF
TAX PROFESSIONAL. SO FOR EXAMPLE
IF THE SENIOR COUPLE PURCHASED A
SMALL RENTAL PROPERTY IN
DECEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN. AND
THEY ARE NOW STRUGGLING DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC IT WOULD BE UNABLE
TO START THE PROCESS. TO
WITHDRAW FROM THE RENTAL HOUSING
MARKET UNTIL DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR- THAT WAS THAT
CLEVELAND IS UNCONSCIONABLE- THE
ELLIS ACT AS RECENTLY AMENDED
WITH BROAD STAKEHOLDER INPUT BY
AB THIRTEEN NINETY NINE BLOOM
STATUTES OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
PROVIDE THE BALANCE MECHANISM
FOR THE STRUGGLING SMALL
PROPERTY OWNERS TO UTILIZE IT'S
A LAST RESORT TO PROTECT THEIR
FAMILIES FROM FURTHER FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP IN SHARP CONTRAST
RESPECTFULLY EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR THEY HAVE BIG PROPOSAL THAT
FAILED TO TAKE THE STRUGGLING
SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS INTO
ACCOUNT. WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR NO VOTE ON. EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. WE'VE HEARD THE THEY
OUT OF ORDER NOT OUT OF ORDER
BUT WE JUST DIDN'T HEAR THEM AT
THE TIME THAT WE CALL THEM
INITIALLY SO WE'VE COVERED ALL
THE OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS WE DO HAVE A
MOTION THIS IS A DO PASS.
SERRANO QUESTIONS THIS IS ON A
B. ROLL CALL. THANK YOU- AB
SEVEN FOUR EIGHT WEEKS FOUR
CARILLO. MOVE THE BELL. THANK
YOU REMOVED PETER SECOND. OKAY
MISTER BRYANT PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN
WENDY CARILLO I'M HERE 2% EIGHTY
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT THISBILL
REQUIRED REQUIRED CALIFORNIA'S
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOLS TO
DISPLAY A POSTER MAKING
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO
STUDENTS ABOUT COMMON MENTAL
HEALTH SYMPTOMS POSITIVE COPING
STRATEGIES AND SCHOOL SITE
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO THEM NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE NEED THESE TYPES OF
RESOURCES. I OPPOSITION BEEN
REMOVED FROM THE BILL WITH
RECENT AMENDMENTS AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
WITNESSES THAT ARE GOING TO
PRESENT SO WE'LL TURN TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THOSE WHO HEARING OR
HEARING THE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR.
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY SEEN
NONE. OF WILL MOVE TO REMOTE
STATION THOSE WHO WERE AT REMOTE
STATION THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL. IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL. HEARING NONE
CRISTINA WELL LET ME JUST MAKE
SURE THAT. OKAY WILL TURN TO THE
OPERATOR FOR ON THE PHONE LINE
IS THERE ANYONE OPERATOR WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
THIS BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB IS
SEVEN FOUR EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THAT ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE TO IN Q. ALIGNMENT NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CARE NUMBER FORTY
DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY PART THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU.
OKAY WILL THEY WILL TURN TO
THOSE WHO WOULD- SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. SYRIAN NINE. THOSE WHO ARE
RUDE BY REMOTE- TESTIMONY
STATION SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION.
C. NINE- WILL MOVE TO THE
OPERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES WHO WERE. RESIDENTS THOSE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OR TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN FOUR
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THAT THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE- THERE HAS BEEN
A MOTION OR ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS HEARING NONE THIS IS
ON THE B. ROLL CALL. GRADUATIONS
ARE REAL I THINK IT'S A RECALL
THANK REGULATIONS THANK YOU. SO
FOR ONE. OKAY THAT'S TWENTY OKAY
NEXT IS SAID AB ELEVEN TWENTY-
WOULD. AFTERNOON THAT COULD HARM
MORNING- MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
CONGRATULATIONS MISTER CHAIR ON
YOUR NEW ASSIGNMENTS- AB ELEVEN
TWENTY WOULD ALLOW HEALTH
FACILITIES AND HOSPITALS TO
AUTHORIZE THE USE OF NEW BLOOD
COLLECTION METHODS AND DEVICES
AS THE ANALYSIS STATES THE
FISCAL IMPACT IS NEGLIGIBLE ON
THE PHONE FOR QUESTIONS AS A
REPRESENTATIVE WITH A LOT OF
WITH. VASCULAR THANK YOU ARE WE
SEE THAT YOU HAVE. ONE MAIN
WITNESS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
AND THAT'S A DOCTOR THE TO.
DEMAGOGUE MY APOLOGIES IF BY.
THE DALLAS PRONOUNCE IT
CORRECTLY BUT IF. THE DOCTORS ON
THE LINE WILL TAKE YOUR
TESTIMONY TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU
ENSURE YOU ACTUALLY GOT IT RIGHT
MY NAME IS DR PEACHY DUMPED ON
THE ADVENTURE OF AN FDA CLEARED
NEEDLE FREE BLOOD DRAW
TECHNOLOGY CALLED KIBO. KIBO THE
SINGLE USE DISPOSABLE DEVICE TO
TEMPORARILY CONNECT TO
HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS PURPLE IV
CATHETER TO ENABLE VIRTUALLY
PAINLESS ARE LIABLE BLOOD DRIVES
THE TRULY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS BUT THE
BILL WILL IMPOSE NEGLIGIBLE IF
ANY COST TO THE STATE. WHICH HAS
BEEN THE CASE IN OTHER STATES
FOR THE TECHNOLOGY WITH
IMPLEMENTED PATIENT SAFETY
PARAMOUNT BUT A LOT OF WILL
NEVER START OR PAUSE ANY RUNNING
INFUSION WELL NOT IN SORT THE
INSERT OR REMOVE ANY IV
CATHETERS AND IS BUILT. EARLY
KEEPS THE NURSE IN CONTROL OF
THE PATIENT IV THERAPY
ADDITIONALLY ALL YOURS COMPLETE
IN PERSON TRAINING AND
DEMONSTRATE COMPETENCY TO
PERFORM THE PROCEDURE NONE OF
WHICH IMPORTANT ANY NEW COSTS TO
THE STATE. THERE IS ROBUST
EVIDENCE SUPPORTING I. B.
CAPITAL BLOOD DRAWS WITH PEOPLE
INCLUDING SIX PEER REVIEWED
PUBLISHED JOURNAL BOND JOURNAL
ARTICLE. INCLUDING OVER TWO AND
IN ADDITION TO THAT OVER TWO AND
A HALF MILLION EOPLE ACROSS IT
AND PERFORMED HALF OF DONE BY
PHLEBOTOMIST OF OTHER STATES
WITHOUT SINGLE. EVENT REPORTED
IN CALIFORNIA TODAY THE MAJORITY
OF BLOOD DRAWS ARE DONE BY
PHLEBOTOMIST AND THIS BILL
ENABLE THEM TO UTILIZE A MORE
HUMANE AND SAFE PROCEDURE TO
DRAW BLOOD FROM THE HEART LIKE
PATIENTS THERE'S A COMMITTEE TO
VOTE I THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE'LL TURN TO ANY. WHO HERE THE
COMING HERE ROOM WOULD LIE TO
SPEAK FAVOR OF THE BILL. THIS IS
ROBERT. BRANCH ON BEHALF OF
INTO. CASES FOR K. THEY HAD AWAY
SO SHE- THANK. LIFE SCIENCES ALL
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I SEE NO OTHER- WILL TURN TO
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION FOR
SUPPORT. SAY NONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES- ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY. IF YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE
END OF THE ROW AT THIS TIME. YOU
HAVE ONE IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THAT MY NUMBER. BY
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
SORRY OR- OPPOSITION- MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSUS PURSLANE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED AB ELEVEN
TWENTY THE CURRENT EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS NOT PREPARE
PHLEBOTOMIST FOR THE CARE AND
MANAGEMENT OF POLITICAL INSERTED
INTO DAMAGE CHAPTERS. IN THE
FACILITY OFFER TECHNICAL
TRAINING IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH TO
ENSURE THAT THE BOTTOM IS CAN
SAFELY USE AN APPARATUS TO
WITHDRAW BLOOD IV CATHETER
SENATE EDUCATION EXPERIENCE TO
CARE FOR ENGINE MANAGER MIGHT BE
IS AN ESSENTIAL REQUIREMENT TO
SAFELY DROPLET SAFELY FROM AN IV
CATHETER AND NON HA CHRISTIAN
HORN. WE CAN JUST BUILD IN AND
UNNECESSARY CHANGE TO A NURSE'S
SCOPE OF PRACTICE SOLELY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF SELLING MORE DEVICES
AND MAXIMIZING PROFITS RIGHT NOW
NURSES ALREADY CAN AND DO USE
GOOGLE DEVICES SAFELY AND
EFFECTIVELY CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
OF PEOPLE DEVICES ONLY
ACCESSIBLE VIA. IN THIS CAPITA
WHICH FOR THE MUSEUM BELONGS THE
NURSES IN THE NURSES CREATED
PARKING IN TERMS OF FISCAL
IMPACT THE MEASURE WILL BRING
UNNECESSARY COSTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WOULD BE CHARGED
WITH THE ADOPTION OF THESE
REGULATIONS- IS CURRENTLY IN THE
MISTER YOU KNOW. HE CREATED IN
THE MIDST OF PROTECTING PEOPLE
AND CALIFORNIA FROM A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AS WELL UNLIKE
ANYTHING THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN A
CENTURY THEY SHOULD NOT BE
CHARGED WITH CREATING MORE
REGULATIONS SO THAT OUR COMPANY
CAN SELL MORE DEVICES. STATE
SIMPLY SHOULD NOT BEAR THE COST
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR LOCAL
TODAY THANK YOU OPERATOR I NEED
YOU AS BEST AS POSSIBLE TO
FOLLOW ALONG WITH ME SO I WAS
TAKING. SUPPORT AND YOU AND IF
COMES ON THE NEXT TIME. BY
ACCIDENT OR OTHERWISE ALL ALL
CUT THEM OFF AND MAKE SURE WE
STAY THAT ORDER SO IS THERE
ANYONE. IS A ON THE PHONE LINE
WHO WOULD TO THEIR SO. FOUR
ELEVEN TWENTY. SEVERAL COMMENT
THANK YOU OKAY WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION WILL CONSIDER THE
LAST BECAUSE I HAVE NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION IN TERMS
OF A MAIN WITNESS SO WE'LL TURN
TO THE HEARING ROOM AT THERE'S
ANYONE WHO'S HERE THAT LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. NOW YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SO SEE NON REMOTE TESTIMONY
OPPOSITION C. NINE WILL MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES. OKAY WE'LL GO
BACK TO REMOTE. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
REMOTE TESTIMONY OPPOSITION NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. ONLY
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE AND I
OPPOSE AB ELEVEN TWENTY THIS
WILL ONLY CREATE MORE ACTS VERY
VERY MUCH ON US TAP THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE.
THAT IS JUST NAME FILIATION. AND
POSITION FROM REMOTE TESTIMONY.
C. NINE WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES IS THEIR OPPOSITION. TO
THE DC BE REGISTERED ON THIS
BILL FROM ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAT SPEND ZERO AT THIS TIME
FOR A BI ELEVEN TWENTY. I DO
HAVE THREE IN Q. WIDE ONE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MATT BROUGHT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS AND
THE ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS
THAT CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I NOW LIVE IN. I'M SORRY LINE AT
ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO KAREN MEMBERS MRS JENNIFER
MALLEY CALLING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN TWENTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIDE ONE
PATENT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS THIS IS
DADDY GRANDMA ON BEHALF OF BSE
W. WESTERN STATE COUNCIL AND
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LINDA BACK AND RESIDENT PLASTER
COUNTY AND I AM IN STRONG%
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THINK YOU'LL
THANK YOU- WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THIS BILL IN A SECOND. NO
COMMENTS THE BILL IS OUT ON A
RECALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
THE WEBER NOT VOTING. OKAY LET'S
SEE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO-
ASSEMBLY BILL. NINE TWENTY
THREE. THIS IS- ROBERT LARA
RAMOS. RAMOS VARANE WITH. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR TO MEMBER- I
WANT TO START UP A IN THE NEXT
THE COMMITTEE AMEND. AB NINE TWO
THREE WILL REQUIRE HEADS OF
STATE AGENCIES. TO BE PROPERLY
TRAINED IN GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT CONSULTATION WITH
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AND CONSIDER
CONSULTATION WITH TRIBES IN THE
POLICY MAKING. WE HAVE SEEN
RECENT EXAMPLES OF THE CONFUSION
THAT TOO OFTEN ARISES AS STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS INTERACT
WITH TRIBES. WE SEE THIS OFTEN
DURING NATURAL EMERGENCIES
WILDFIRES. EARTHQUAKES AND MOST
RECENTLY THE PANDEMIC.
INFORMATION SHARING CAN RESULT
IN DANGEROUS SITUATIONS AND LACK
OF ACCESS TO AVAILABLE EIGHT.
THIS BILL IS EXPECTED TO HAVE
MINIMAL FISCAL IMPACT WHILE
HAVING A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
THE QUALITY OF RELATIONSHIP FOR
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS MAKE THIS BILL
STRONGER BY MOVING THE TRAINING
DEVELOPMENT FROM THE OFFICE OF
TRAVEL ADVISOR TO EXTEND
TRAINING DEVELOPMENT TO THOSE
BEST SUITED. FOR THE STATE'S
ONBOARDING PROCESS. HERE WITH ME
TO TESTIFY ARE OUR SPONSORS WITH
THE BILL- I BELIEVE THEY'RE HERE
IN PERSON OR ON THE PHONE LINE.
IS FRANK MOLINA REPRESENTING THE
SALMON WHAT TRIBAL GOVERNMENT.
AND MISTER SCOTT GOVERNOR
REPRESENTING THE MORONGO TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU YOUR
WITNESSES MAY PROCEED. TWO
MINUTES EACH. I'M NOT SURE THEY
MADE A MISTAKE OKAY THE PHONE
ARE THEY ARE NOT THE OWNER YEAH
DO WE HAVE- THE WITNESSES THAT
ARE AND TESTON IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL ON THE WITNESS I MEAN
ON THE PHONE LINE. I DON'T SEE
EITHER OF THOSE DIALED IN AS
SPEAKERS OKAY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILL. WILL WITH THE MEN IF THEY
HAPPEN TO COME IN AS WE MAKE OUR
WAY THROUGH THE REST OF THE
TESTIMONY- ME WITNESSES- WILL
WAIT ON US COMMITTEE HEARING
ROOM FOR ANYONE WHO IS PREPARED
TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. SEE NON REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION IN SUPPORT. C.
NINE MOVED TO THE PHONE LINE.
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT. WE'RE AB
FIVE NINETY FIVE. I'M SORRY NOT. NINE TWENTY FIFTY THREE NINETY
THREE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE TWO
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE
END ZERO AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU OKAY I
DON'T HAVE ANYONE REGISTERED FOR
OPPOSITION AS A WITNESS IS THERE
ANYONE ONLINE- IN THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM. AS A WITNESS
ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING
ROOM WHO IS HERE TO SPEAK TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. PROMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
SAY NINE ANY OPPOSITION OKAY I'M
SORRY WILL GO BACK TO REMOTE-
TESTIMONY TO REGISTER YOUR
OPPOSITION NAME. FILIATION AND
POSITION OF OPPOSITE YES MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE AND I OPPOSE A. B.
NINE TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS ALICIA AND I OPPOSE
AB NINE TWENTY THREE. MY NAME IS
ANDREA AND I OPPOSE AB. NINE
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU SEE NO
OTHER OKAY. HELLO PLEASE PERCENT
HI I'M JULIUS AND I OPPOSE AB.
NINE TWO THREE. I SEE NO OTHER
OPPOSITION TO- THEY WANT TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION REMOTE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR-
OPPOSITION- TO ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINE TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO AB NINE TWO THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DEBBIE HAAS WITH RESOLUTE ON
BEHALF OF UPPER LAKE AND WE
HAVE- AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. Q. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT. OKAY WE HAVE- A DO
PASSED AS AMENDED I WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IF THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THAN THIS IS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU. THREE HOURS.
THREE THREE NINE NINE OKAY.
SEVEN MEMBER SALAS ASSEMBLY BILL. THREE NINE NINE. THANK RESERVE
TERM MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO
RESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINE
NINE WHICH ALLOWS AN INJURED
EMPLOYEE TO REQUEST A MEDICAL
PROVIDER NETWORK NAME AND
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER FOR THE
EMPLOYER AND INSTANCES WHERE THE
EMPLOYER OBJECTS TO AN INJURED
EMPLOYEE SELECTION OF A
PHYSICIAN ON THE GROUND THAT THE
PHYSICIAN IS NOT WITHIN THE
MEDICAL PROVIDER NETWORK USED BY
THE EMPLOYER. I MEMBERS I CAN
TELL YOU THIS IS JUST A MEASURE
THAT WE'VE CRAFTED WITH
EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE- THIS IS
A COMPROMISE AND HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. I WILL I
DO HAVE TESTIFYING VIA THE
TELEPHONE LINES DOCTOR JAKE UP
MOVED AVAILABLE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF INDUSTRIAL
MEDICINES BEEN APPROVED. MAIN
WITNESS I DO. AB DOCTOR JAKE UP-
ROSENBERG. K. IF HE'S HERE WELL
HERE'S PRESENTATION NOW. I
BELIEVE HE'S ON THE TELEPHONE ON
THE PHONE LINE PHONE OPERATOR IF
YOU COULD- ALERT DR JACOB
ROSENBERG. EVITE HAVE OPENED UP. THANK YOU HI AN ACCURATE BURKE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
. THAT SURGERIES STARTUP BACKED
OUT. THE STRAIGHT BILL IT REALLY
DOES POSE- AND HE SIGNIFICANCE
BURDEN ON- THE INSURANCE COMPANY
OUT THERE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
THIS INFORMATION- THIS JUST
GIVES US A MECHANISM TO DO THAT
SOMETIMES- THE MEDICAL PROVIDER
NETWORK IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
DETERMINE. AT WHAT THAT HAPPENS
OF PATIENTS BUT WE CAN'T FIND A
TREATING PHYSICIAN THEY CAN'T
GET TREATMENT- AND IT REALLY
DELAYS CARE. AND WHEN THAT
HAPPENS UNFORTUNATELY- THEIR
INJURIES. WE WILL BECOME STABLE
FOR THE- SO- THIS WILL HELP
RESOLVE THAT. HAITIANS THE
INJURED WORKERS HAVE YET TO
DETERMINE THE RIGHT DOCTOR TO
TREAT THEM- WITHIN THE MEDICAL
PROVIDER NETWORK IS DESIGNATED
BY THE INSURANCE COMPANY. AS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS SAID WE'RE
BOB PRACTICE THIS BILL WITH THE
INPUT FROM. OF THE INSURANCE
COMMUNITY- AND THEY WERE CLEAR
THAT. I RECOGNIZE THE RESPONSE
BUT THIS WILL HELP HELP THEM
MEET THEIR RESPONSIBILITY. I HAD
A WILL HELP PATIENTS GET
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT PLAN GOSH
SO THERE REALLY SHOULDN'T BE ANY
OPPOSITION SINCE WE CRAFTED
WITHOUT- VERY SPECIFICALLY. TO
AVOID PLACING THE BURDEN OFF OF
THE STATE HI RESOLVING AN ISSUE
THAT THAT THE PROBLEMATIC FOR
SOME TALK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM I WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT. SEE NON
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
REGISTER IN SUPPORT THE NINE AND
THE PHONE LINES OPERATORS ARE
ANYONE ONLINE THEY WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT HOW FOR
AB THREE NINE NINE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE NINE NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAT BENDS THE ROLE AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU WILL MOVE TO MAIN
WITNESS OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO
MAIN WITNESS- THAT HAS
REGISTERED SO WE'LL MOVE TO.
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. BEUVE
TO REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
OPPOSITION NAME FILIATION
APPOSITION. HI MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE A. B. THREE NINE NINE
I OPPOSE THIS IS JUST MORE RED
TAPE WORKINGMEN'S MONETIZATION
THE GOVERNMENT LAWYER WHO.
PLEASE PROCEED NAME HI I'M
JEALOUS AND I OPPOSE AB THREE
NINE NINE. THANK YOU. CHAIR MY
NAME ASSURING A LARGE AND I
OPPOSE AB THREE NINE NINE I THIS
IS JUST. ANOTHER COMMUNIST BELL
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS RICHARD
ROBY ARC. HOME SUFFER ALL THE
RED TAPE OF WORKERS COMP I
OPPOSE. DEFINITELY AB THREE NINE
NINE. HI I'M ANDREA I'M BACK AYE
OPPOSED AB THREE NINE NINE AND
YOU NEED TO OPEN THE BILL. WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE PHONE LINE. IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO BE
REGISTERED ON THE PHONE LINE. IF
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE DIED NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAT SAYS ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I DO HAVE TO IN Q.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT. I HAVE
THREE IN Q. THE FIRST ONE COMES
FROM WIDE ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LINDA
BUCHNER WITH LAUGHTER COUNTY I
AM VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED TO THIS
AND- I CAN GET THAT OPEN. AND
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
THANK YOU NEXT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ANNETTE ST I'M ON A
GIVEN CHARLES KENNEDY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. EXPAND YOUR
RIGHT ONE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME IS WALDRON
ANDERSON AYE OPPOSED A BILL AB.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED. NINE ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS BARBARA AND I OPPOSE
EIGHTY THREE NINE NINE. I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE NO SAY NO COMMENTS FOR
MANY MEMBERS- THIS BILL IS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. THANK REST
ASSURED LIKE YOU MEMBERS THANK
YOU. MISTER O'DONNELL- AB. NINE
OH TWO. THIS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS EIGHTY NINE OH
TWO ESTABLISHES AN ALTERNATIVE
DESIGN BUILD A PILOT PROJECT FOR
AWARDING SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS THE JURY TRADITIONAL
METHOD FOR AWARDING CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTS IS DESIGN BID BUILD
WHERE SCHOOL DISTRICT FIRST
HIRED AN ARCHITECT TO DESIGN A
SCHOOL THEN GOES OUT TO BID FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION CONTRACT. UNDER
DESIGN BUILD A SCHOOL DISTRICT
SEEKS BIDS FOR BOTH THE DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION OF THE PROJECT.
AB NINE OH TWO ALLOWS A LIMITED
NUMBER OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
AWARD AN INITIAL PLAN THAT DOES
NOT INCLUDE THE CONSTRUCTION
COSTS AND INSTEAD ALLOWS A
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO RENEGOTIATE.
WITH THE DESIGN BUILD TEAM ONCE
THERE'S A DESIGN. THIS WILL HELP
INSURE THAT THE PRICE A SCHOOL
DISTRICT PAYS IS MORE IN LINE
WITH THE TRUE COST FOR
CONSTRUCTION. LAST YEAR THROUGH
A BUDGET TRAILER BILL THE
STATE'S DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES RECEIVED AUTHORITY TO
USE PROGRESSIVE DESIGN BUILD.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A SIMILAR
PROCESS FOR DISTRICTS WITH FIFTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS OR MORE OF
EIGHTY EIGHT. IT'S ABOUT ELEVEN
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
IS ONLY AN OPTION AND HAS NO
STATE COST. TESTIFYING BY PHONE
AS MARTHA ALVAREZ WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL. THE
BILL. IT'S BEEN ROUTED THEIR
SECOND. THREE MILLION SECOND-
WILL TURN TO YOUR MAIN WITNESS
MR MARC ALVAREZ. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PRESENT YOUR POSITION. HI GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARTHA ALBERTS A TELEVANGELIST
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
WE'RE PLEASED TO SPONSOR EIGHTY
NINE OH TWO BUILDING I'M SURE
DONALD COMMENTS. BEHIND BUILDERS
AND- SUBCONTRACTORS WOULD NO
LONGER NEED TO ADD CONTINGENCIES
TO THEIR PROPOSALS TO COVER
FUTURE UNCERTAINTIES THE FINAL
CONSTRUCTION COSTS ARE
ANTICIPATED TO BE LOWER RESULT
IN SAVINGS WE DO NOT YOU EIGHTY
NINE OH TO WHAT'S HAPPENING AND
IF IT'S GOING BACK TO THE STATE.
OR LOCAL FACILITY PROJECTS PAID
WITH LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON
RESOURCES AND THE FINAL
EVALUATION REPORT WILL BE REAL
RESPONSIBILITY PARTICIPATING
SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR THIS REASON-
TO IT INCREASED EFFICIENCY AND
RESULT IN COST SAVINGS THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IS PLEASED TO SPONSOR EIGHTY
NINE OH TWO. YOUR I. BOATS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OF DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR THE
BILL REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT SEE. NON WILL TURN TO THE REMOTE.
TESTIMONIES TO. OF FOR SUPPORT
SEE NON. PHONE OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ONLINE I WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY OR TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT FOR- EIGHTY NINE OH TWO.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB NIGHT- TO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END OF
THE ROW AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SEE NON A
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
OPPOSITION NAME. AFFILIATION
PHYSICIAN. HI MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE AND I OPPOSE AB. NINE
OH TWO. HI AM JULIUS AND I
OPPOSE AB NINE OH TWO. HELLO MY
NAME IS MAX BORNEO AND I LIKE TO
OPPOSE AB NINE OH TWO. SECONDLY
YOU DON'T GO TO CHURCH IS
RICHARD. HI OPPOSE AB INTERNAL
TO. THIS IS YOUR IN A LATCH
AGAIN I OPPOSE AB NINE OH TWO
AND YOU HAVE TO STOP LAUGHING AT
US IN THERE THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
THIS IS CATHERINE AND I OPPOSE
AB NINE OH TWO. THANK YOU VOTE
NO. HI MY NAME IS ANDREA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I OPPOSE
YOU CENSORING PUBLIC COMMENT IN
THE PORTS HEARINGS UNDER LOAD ON
THE BUILDING MOVED TO THE- PHONE
LINE OPERATOR. HAVE WE DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ONLINE THAT OPPOSES
THIS BILL LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB NINE OH TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AT THE END OF THE ROW AT THIS
TIME. RIGHT ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER COUNTY I LIVE CLOSE TO
EIGHTY NINE OH TWO. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT. THANK
YOU COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT'S BEEN HIS EMOTIONS AND-
THE IT'LL BE OUT ON A. B. ROLL
CALL WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
. IT'LL BE AN AB WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT LIVING. IN THIS
DAVIES OKAY NOW. SO THE BILL IS
OUT- REPUBLICANS AND REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING AND MISS DAVIS VOTING
NO. OKAY THEY MISTER THANK YOU
TEMPERATURES COMMITTEE. OKAY
WE'LL MOVE TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHO HAVE PRESENTATIONS TO BE
MADE THE MOVE TO THE TOP- WITH-
MISTER OF THE SIMILAR RIVAS FOR
MISTER BLOOM A. B. SIX EIGHTY
TWO. YOU CAN. SWITCHES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- PLEASED TO PRESENT
THE BELL- AB SIXTY TWO ON BEHALF
OF THE MOVE TO UNDERSTAND A
MEASURE TO INCENTIVIZE CO
HOUSING APARTMENTS ALSO KNOWN AS
SOME COMMUNAL LIVING THE MEASURE
HAS NO OPPOSITION WILL OCCUR US
A MINIMAL COST TO THE STATE- I
BELIEVE THAT HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS RAIN- THE- SORRY RAIN
MOVED TO PORT IN THE- WAY THAT.
I'M SORRY I CAN'T READ IT- LOW
BOARD I BELIEVE- WHO IS
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF CITY LAB
AT UCLA. THANK YOU MR THANK YOU
. I WILL TURN TO THE MAIN
WITNESS- IF THEY'RE NOT HERE AND
THE HEARING ROOM- ARE THEY ON
THE PHONE LINE OPERATOR CAN YOU
CHECK TO SEE IF THE- I AM ON THE
PHONE LINE. OKAY RANIERE A-
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS O
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME OF BRAIN
MCCORD GRAYSON AND ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF SPENDING A LOT OF
UCLA. THIRTY LIVE YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY TWO AND WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MAN BLAME BIRTH OPERATE
FROM THE CONCORDANT ISSUE.
CALIFORNIANS WELL DOCUMENTED
HOUSING CRISIS REQUIRES MANY
SOLUTION. SB SIX EIGHTY TO
CREATE THE NEW HOUSING TYPOLOGY
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN LEGAL FOR
MANY REASONS TONING AND
OTHERWISE. AND HELPS PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL UNITS TO ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING SHORTAGE SB SIX THIRTY
TO ALLOW DEVELOPERS TO BOKO
HOUSING APARTMENT BY COMPLY WITH
LOCAL REQUIREMENTS. OF SMALLER
UNITS BUT INCLUDE A BATHROOM
SINK REFRIGERATOR AND MICROWAVE.
KITCHENS AND DINING SPACES WILL
BE SHARED AMONG RESIDENTS. I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT. THE BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. WELL TO ANYONE HERE
IN THE MAIN HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE REMOTE TESTIMONY. C.
NINE. THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
IS THERE ANYONE ONLINE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT. FOUR EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
TWO. IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX EIGHT TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU. OKAY WE
MOVED OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION C. NINE. REMOTE
TESTIMONY. NAME YEAH AFFILIATION
AND POSITION YES MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE THIS A BE A SIX EIGHT
TWO FOR PLANNING AND ZONING FOR
ALL THE DENSITY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE. MY NAME'S
KATHERINE AND I OPPOSE SB SIX OH
TWO AND YOUR ENTIRE COMMUNIST
AGENDA. HI THIS IS YOUR IN A
LARGE AGAIN I'M GOING TO OPPOSE
AB SIX EIGHT TWO. WE SHOULD WE
SHOULD BE HEARING THIS TODAY
PERIOD. POLICIA I OPPOSE AB SIX
EIGHT TWO. THE NAME IS MAX AND I
OPPOSE AB. SIX EIGHT TWO. MY
NAME IS JULIUS AND I OPPOSE AB.
SIX EIGHT TWO. MRS RICHARD HI
THANK YOUR PLANNING ZONING IS A
JOKE AYE OPPOSED SAY B. SIX
EIGHTY TWO. MY NAME IS ANDREA
AND I OPPOSE AB SIX EIGHT TO
BLOOM AND YOU NEED TO OPEN THE
BUILDING THIS IS THE PEOPLE'S
HOUSE. THE NEW MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINE OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB SIX EIGHT
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ARE YOU OF A
COUPLE IN CUBA WHY NO ONE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND WHAT IS
YOUR RUNNING. I WANT TO WAIT FOR
YOU KNOW I HAD. MY NAME IS LINDA
AND I OPPOSED EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
TWO. THANK YOU BYE NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS. EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I WILL BRING IT BACK TO. THE
COMMITTEE UP THERE NO QUESTIONS
OF THIS BILL IS SET OUT. ON A-
WAS OUR SECOND I THINK WE CAN
GET THIS TO THEMOVE MR LEVINE
YOUR SECOND. THANK THE B. THE
BILL IS OUT OF THE B. ROLL CALL
WITH FONG NOT VOTING- THE
SERVICE YOU'RE YOU'RE STILL UP
FOR MR MEDINA- THIS IS A B. FIVE
NINE FIVE. SO ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. BUT STATE
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINE FIVE.
SIX TO REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY TRUSTEES. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA BOARD%
OF REGENTS TO ENGAGE IN A-
SPECIFIED PROCESS PRIOR TO
ADDING A NEW UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENT.
COSTS ASSOCIATE WITH THIS BILL
ARE- VERY MINIMAL. AND WITH US
HERE TO- DEPARTMENT TO- PROVIDES
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AS MANY
RODRIGUEZ FROM ED TRUST WEST
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. GOOD
MORNING SHAREHOLDING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NAMES MANY RODRIGUEZ
SHARE BEHALF EDUCATION TRUST
WEST. FIRST WE'D LIKE TO THINK
SOMEBODY DEEP MEDINA FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
EQUITABLE ACCESS AND
TRANSPARENCY. I'LL START OFF BY
SAYING THAT THIS BILL IS
EMBEDDED WITH PRINCIPLES THAT
SHOULD BE A BASELINE FOR
EDUCATION POLICY. THOSE ARE
INCLUSIVITY TRANSPARENCY
COORDINATION AND EQUITY. WHAT
OUR POST SECONDARY SEGMENTS
WHERE ANY FUTURE ELIGIBILITY
CHANGE WE MUST ENSURE THAT WE
KNOW THE DISPARATE IMPACT SHE
STUDENT GROUPS SHE REGION AS
WELL AS THE WHOLE SENIOR CLASS.
NOT JUST THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY
ON TRACK TOWARDS COLLEGE.
FURTHERMORE AS AN ORGANIZATION
WHOSE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR STATES
ON THE CURRENT IMPLEMENTATION
CHIP COMMITTEE FOR THE CSU
QUANTITY OF REASON PROPOSAL. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THE
INCLUSIVITY TRANSPARENCY AND
AUTHENTICATE GAZING CARRIES OVER
TO THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE. OUR
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN ONE WHERE
KEY QUESTIONS HAVE NOT BEEN
ADDRESSED AND OVERALL
COMMUNICATION WITH THE COMMITTEE
DOES NOT SEEM TO REFLECT THE
INTENTION OF THE TWO YEAR
PROCESS. NEEDLER PLEASE PAST
EXPERIENCES AND ENSURE THE
ELIGIBILITY CHANGES CAN BE
ADVANCED WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT OR
MEANINGFUL INPUT FROM K. TWELVE
STAKEHOLDERS AND WITHOUT AN
UPFRONT AND CLEAR DISPARATE
IMPACT. AB FIVE NINE FIVE WILL
ENSURE THAT ANY FUTURE CHANGES
DO NOT FURTHER JEOPARDIZED
EQUITABLE ACCESS FOR STUDENTS
AND ESTABLISHED EQUITY GUARD
RAILS SO MANY STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
DEMANDED FROM THE BEGINNING.
WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
HERE I. THANK YOU THANK YOU I
WILL TURN TO ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT. FOR AB FIVE NINE FIVE.
WE'LL TURN TO THE REMOTE- REMOTE
TESTIMONY. FOR SUPPORT SAY NINE
MOVED TO THE PHONE LINES.
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE I WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT FOR A BI
FIVE NINE FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT FOR AB
FIVE NINE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAT THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHY
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING NOT TOO CHALLENGING
ON BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY WE SUPPORT
A. B. OBVIOUS BY THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATION AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
OFFERS OTHERS OFFICES
STRENGTHENED PROPOSAL FURTHER.
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU.
WE'LL TURN TO OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
SEE NON. WILL MOVE TO REMOTE
TESTIMONY. OPPOSITION. TWO FIVE
NINE FIVE. PLEASE VISIT. HI IT'S
ALICIA I OPPOSE AB. FIVE NINETY
FIVE. ALL RIGHT HOW IS THIS YOUR
LOGIC AND OPPOSING AB FIVE
NINETY FIVE THANKS. SIX HELLO MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE I'M OPPOSING
AB FIVE NINE FIVE I'D REALLY
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU. CLICK
HERE. MORE MY NAME'S KATHERINE
AYE OPPOSED AB. FIVE NINE FIVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS MAX AND I
OPPOSE AB FIVE NINE FIVE. HELLO
MY NAME IS ANDREA I OPPOSE AB
FIVE NINE FIVE BUT I THINK YOU.
FOR YOUR TO MOVE- NO ONE S. B.
TWO SEVEN SIX MY BODY MY CHOICE
INCLUDES VACCINES WE WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE ON TO- THE PHONE LINE.
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION TO AB
FIVE NINE FIVE. IF YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB FIVE NINE FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THE END ZERO AT THIS TIME
. RIGHT ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS BARBER AND I
OPPOSE AB FIVE NINE FIVE. THANK
YOU AYE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AB FIVE BOND. THANK YOU I'M MORE
TO EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS LINDA AND I OPPOSE
EIGHTY FIVE NINE FIVE. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU WILL BRING THAT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE WITH NO COMMENTS- THIS
IS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. I WILL
MOVE BACK TO. AB FIVE TWENTY TWO
SEVERAL FAR. TO DO PASSED. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AT THIS BILL
EXTENDS THE FILM. THANK YOU THIS
BILL EXTENDS THE FOR FIRE
PREVENTION TIMBER HARVEST PLAN
EXEMPTION FROM FEBRUARY
NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY SIX BY
EXITING THE SUNSET DATE OF THE
PILOT PROJECT- THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW LANDOWNERS TO SUSTAINABLY
INCREASE THE PACE AND SCALE OF
HEALTHY FORCE MANAGEMENT. AND
HELP CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE ITS FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE GOAL OF
TREATED LAND THE COMMITTEE NOW
SAYS NO TO THIS EXTENSION OF A
NEGLIGIBLE STATE COSTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. ABOUT THANK
YOU I WILL NOW MOVE TO. ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT.
MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN REYES
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANY SUPPORT ON POLICY
GROUNDS THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
SEE NO OTHER WILL TURN TO REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SCENE NO ONE
A TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT MOVED TO
THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR. ANYONE
ONLINE TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
FOR AB FIVE TWENTY TWO. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE TWO TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT TEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I HAVE A COUPLE AND
HE WILL GO TO ONE SIXTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHRIS
ROSA ON BEHALF OF KELP FORESTS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOUR TO JUST
BE ONE MOMENT FOR THE NEXT
COMMENT. AND ONE OH THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CLEAN GREETING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU. I WILL TURN TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION SEEN ON REMOTE
TESTIMONY OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PROCEED. WE CAN'T WE CAN'T HEAR
TO CHILL THANK YOU FONG. OKAY
YOU CAN'T HEAR ME WE JUST GOT
YOU YES WE DO IT WAS NOT ON AT
THE BEGINNING BUT WE DID CATCH
YOUR YOUR COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU SO YOU GOT THAT I
SUPPORT AB FIVE TWO TWO FOUR
FONG. HELLO THIS A LATCH. AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE TWO
TWO THANK YOU FONG. HI EVERYONE
TOGETHER THIS IS CATHERINE
MCBRIDE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
TWO TWO THANK YOU. HI THIS IS
ALICIA IN SUPPORT OF AB B. FIVE
TWO TWO THANK YOU FONG. HELLO MY
NAME IS MAX AND I'M SUPPORTING
AB FIVE TWO TWO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FONG FOR HOLDING THE
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET. MY NAME IS ANDREA I
SUPPORT AB FIVE TWO TWO FONG FOR
GOVERNOR. WHERE THERE IS. A GUY
THAT HAS THE MAGIC SAUCE ALL
RIGHT. WILL WILL MOVE. TO WILL
MOVE TO- THE GOOD BILL IT'S A
GOOD BILL. IF THE UNIT IS THE
UNIFIED BILL AREA HELLO TO THE
PHONE LINES IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE TWO TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE OF THIS
BILL IS OUT ON A ROLL CALL WITH
MR STONE BUILDING NOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. MISTER LANE
YOU HAVE A COUPLE OF BILLS-
TWENTY SEVEN AND AB FOURTEEN
FORTY FIVE BOTH TO PASS. MOVING
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M BILLS TO
OUR SECOND WHO'S BEEN SECONDED
BY. APRIL TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
DIRECT THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION TO CONSIDER
AMENDMENTS THE ROOF REPLACEMENT
STANDARDS FOR EXISTING LOW RISE
STEEP SLOPE RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS WITH THE GOAL OF
INCREASING. THE MINIMUM SOLAR
REFLECTANCE OF ROUTES FROM POINT
TO- TO POINT FOR- AN EXPANDING
NUMBER OF CLIMATE ZONES WERE
ENERGY EFFICIENT ROOFS ARE
REQUIRED AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS COSTS ARE MINOR AND
ABSORBABLE TRYING TO REDUCE HEAT
ISLANDS AND IMPROVE PUBLIC
HEALTH. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO. REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
. OR AB TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN. C.
NINE WILL MOVE TO REMOTE THE
TESTIMONY STATION IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN. C. NINE
WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE LINE
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT FOR A BI
. TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
FOR A BI TALK TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SO WE'LL
MOVE- TUDE. MOVED TO OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR OPPOSITION. SEE NON REMOTE
TESTIMONY TO HEAR OPPOSITION
NAME AFFILIATION AND COMPOSITION. FORMAL COUNTY PLEASE PRESS YES
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE AB ONE TWO
TWO SEVEN I OPPOSE SENSE WHAT
UNION IS BACKING THIS. HI THIS
ALICIA AND I OPPOSE AB ONE TWO
TWO SEVEN. MY NAME'S KATHERINE
AND I OPPOSE AB ONE TWO TWO
SEVEN. THANK YOU. THIS IS YOUR
LIFE AGAIN AND I'M CALLING TO
STILL LIVE IN SONOMA COUNTY.
SHAME ON YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
MAX AND I'M REPORTING TO OPPOSE
AB ONE TWO TWO SEVEN THANK YOU.
HI MODULUS NAM OPPOSING AB ONE
TWO TWO SEVEN. MY NAME IS ANDREA
AND I OPPOSE AB ONE TWO TWO
SEVEN I USED TO LIVE IN MARC
LEVINE IS DISTRICT AND WE'RE
DONE WITH THE COMMUNISM TO THE
PHONE LINE IS THERE OPERATORS
ARE ANYONE WHO IS ON THE PHONE
LINE I WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR- OPPOSITION. IF YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB AT TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS THE ONE AT THE END OF THE
ROW AT THE TIME. WHITE ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS BARBARA I OPPOSE ONE TWO TWO
SEVEN. THANK YOU BYE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME. WELL
THANK YOU LINE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LANDS COMMITTEE
HOLIDAY AND I OPPOSE THIS. THANK
YOU Y. AND ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS LINDA
BUCHNER IN AYE OPPOSED BOTH.
TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU I HAVE
ONE LASTING HERE LINE ONE FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR CHRIS BOLLINGER ON BEHALF
THE ASPHALT ROOFING
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
MORE COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SAY NO COMMENTS THIS
BILL IS OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL
. MR LEVINE- A. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE
REQUIRES ACCOUNTABLE
DEVELOPMENTS A DELEGATE SUB
REGION OR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO CONSIDER
EMERGENCY EVACUATION. ROUTE
CAPACITY WILDFIRE RISK SEALEVEL
RISE AND OTHER IMPACTS IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE WHEN
ALLOCATING HOUSING NEED IN THEIR
METHODOLOGY FOR THE REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS- PROCESS AS NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS ON GOING COST
EACH CD. TO VALUATE DATA AND
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO IMPLEMENT
THIS BILL WILL BE MINOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU WILL TURN TO-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM IF THERE'S ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT SEE NON. REMOTE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT SAYING
NINE. OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT.
FOR A BI FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT FOR AB FOURTEEN FORTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. OKAY WE'VE
MOVED OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SAY NONE LOW TESTIMONY
OPPOSITION. HI THIS IS ALICIA
AND I OPPOSE A. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY FIVE. RIGHT TO LIFE. I'M
NOT GOING TO BE ME AND IT'S NOT
HI MY NAME IS YOU'RE IN A LARGE
AN OPPOSING AB FOURTEEN FORTY
FIVE I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU GUYS
ARE DOING THIS REZONING THING I
THINK IT'S- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TERRIBLE. THANK YOU. THAT'S NOT
HELLO MY NAME'S KATHERINE AND I
OPPOSE AB. FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE.
HI MY NAME IS MAX AND I OPPOSE
AB FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE. WE NEVER
. MY NAME IS JULIUS AND I OPPOSE
AB ONE FOUR FOUR FIVE. HI MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE AND I OPPOSE
AB ONE FOUR FOUR FIVE SINCE THE
TRAIN TO NOWHERE SUPPOSED TO
HELP WITH HOUSING. YOU ARE THE
PEOPLE I'M STILL A ANDREA AND
WE'RE ALL OPPOSED INCLUDING ME
TO AB ONE FOUR FOUR FIVE AND I
DEFINITELY OPPOSE MARC LEVINE
MAKE MY DAUGHTER CRY TO
CHRISTMAS PARTY. OKAY WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINE- OPERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
. REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION. HI
TO A. B. FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTEEN
FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THE END OF THE ROW AT THE
TIME. WHY ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT ONE TO ONE. I
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS WE'RE NOT GONNA LET THE.
FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT SEVENTYSEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND IS TO THE HOLIDAY
AND I OPPOSE FOURTEEN FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU MIGHT WANT TO
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS LINDA BUCHNER IN I AM OPPOSED
FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU I
DO HAVE ONE MORE IF YOU WERE
GOING TO BE ONE MOMENT ABOUT WHY
NUMBER. EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS NICOLE AND I
OPPOSE FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. OKAY WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
THIS COMMITMENT TO LIVING. YOU
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER HAVING MR
FONG PRESENT FOR YOU NEXT TIME.
WHEN WE ALL THE SUPPORT. SHOUT
OUT TO BE ROLL CALL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE. I MISS
MCCARTY YOU HAVE TO BILLS AB
SEVEN FORTY- UNDER THE SEVEN
FOUR YEAR WITH THE PRESENTATION
OKAY. SO WE'LL TURN THIS IS ON-
MCCARTY. WE'RE JUST WAITING
PRESENTATION. FIFTY POUNDS SO TO
DO PASS. THIRTY SO YOU HAVE NO
WHAT YOU DON'T WANT 2% ON THE
BILL OKAY. I DON'T PRESENTATION
FOR. YOU'RE NOT PULLING VOTE NO
OKAY SO I GETS OUT MY NAME. OKAY
SOLICITED ECONOMY YEAH YEAH. THE
BILL. IT BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
. OF WE HAVE- WILL TURN TO OF.
PUBLIC IN THE- KERN ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE WHO IS PRESENT THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. SEE NON REMOTE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. C. NINE WE
MOVED TO THE- TELEPHONE LINE
OPERATORS ANYONE WHO IS ON THE
TELEPHONE LINE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO- SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
FORTY. IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE IF AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BECAUSE YOU
ARE IN HERE JUST ONE MORE FOR
THAT NUMBER. FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN GREENSPAN ASHER ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION OR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO OPPOSITION. ON
AB SEVEN FORTY IN THE HEARING
ROOM SAY NON PROMOTE TESTIMONY
OPPOSITION TO SEVEN FORTY. SIX I
JUST WANT TO FIND TREATMENT YEAH
THIS IS A LISA AND I'M IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN FORTY.
HELLO THIS IS STEPHANIE AB SEVEN
FOUR ZERO I THINK WE SHOULD GO
BACK TO TRUANCY OFFICERS AND
REDUCE THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND HANK YOU NEXT SALARY. MAX
BAKER PLEASE. MY NAME'S
KATHERINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN FORTY THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS SERENA AND I'M OPPOSING AB.
SEVEN FORTY. I'M JULIE IS AN AYE
OPPOSED AB SEVEN FOUR ZERO. I'M
MAX AND I OPPOSE AB SEVEN FOUR
ZERO. I'M STILL A ANDREA AND I
OPPOSE ALL THIS NONSENSE
DEFINITELY I OPPOSE MCCARTY AND
I OPPOSE AB SEVEN FOUR ZERO AND
YOU NEED TO OPEN THE BUILDING
THIS IS THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE. OKAY
WE WILL TURN TO THE PHONE LINE-
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION. STE
STE THANK YOU IFYOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
SEVEN FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE IF
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WIDE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF
YOU'RE SURE MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN FOUR ZERO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT WOULD BE A
HOLIDAY DISABLED AMERICANS AND
OPPOSE THIS. THANK YOU I WON
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS BARBARA AND AYE OPPOSED
EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY VEHEMENTLY.
THANK YOU I'M ONE OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
LINDA AND I OPPOSE THIS MEASURE
AND IF YOU WANT THE RECEPTIONIST
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS YOU'LL-
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THIS KIND OF MOTION HAS BEEN
SECONDED THE BILL IS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. ERIC THAT CONCLUDES
OUR- THE CONCLUDES OUR REGULAR
ORDER. THE BILLS THAT NEEDED TO
BE PRESENT AT- I'D LIKE TO NOW
MOVES TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT. AND
OPEN UP THE HEARING TO COMMENTS
BY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON ANY
BILL NOT PRESENTED TO THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. PLEASE BE SURE
TO LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL. IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO STATE
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL.
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
NOW. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AT MEMBERS MY NAME IS ROUGHLY
GOAL QUITE YOUNG- LET'S BEGIN BY
HALF OF THE PRISONERS NETWORK
AND TO BLOCK OF THAT GOAL. IS
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED. KALRA AT EIGHTY FIFTEEN
ALTUVE MURATSUCHI THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS OF
STYLE THE CZECHO WITH THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND IS STRONG
SUPPORT TO AB THREE SIX FIVE
O'DONNELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I. SEE NO OTHER WHO WOULD LIKE
TO FROM THE PUBLIC SPEAK ON
OTHER MATTERS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY WILL TURN TO THE
- REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION I
WOULD LIKE TO STATE THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL. AND THIS
AGAIN IS THE NAME. ORGANIZATION
COMPOSITION ON THE BILL. HI MY
NAME IS ALICIA HERNANDEZ AND I
OPPOSE A. B. FOURTEEN HUNDRED.
HI I'M JEALOUS AND I OPPOSE A.
B. FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND ALL
OTHER BILLING THE GOVERNMENT
TRYING TO INFRINGE ON OUR RIGHTS. HI MY NAME'S KATHERINE AND AYE
OPPOSED VEHEMENTLY AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED NO NEW TAXES AND NO
COMMUNIST MEDICAL AGENDAS THANK
YOU. I REMEMBER TIME WE'RE JUST
OPPOSITION. HELLO MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE AND I AM HERE TO
OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED THERE
SHOULD BE NO GOVERNMENT RAN
HEALTHCARE YOU HAVE NOT EVEN HAD
THE FIGHT VERY MANY. PLEASE.
THIS IS YOUR IN A LATCH AND I'M
GOING IN TO STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED YOU WILL NOT
TAKE AWAY OUR NEXT SPEAKER. YOU
WILL NOT TAKE AWAY MY GROUP WE-
AWAY FROM. HELLO MY NAME IS MAX
IN THIS IS THE MOMENT WE'VE ALL
BEEN WAITING FOR I'M HERE TO
POSE AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED. HI
THIS IS RICHA EUROPAEA ASK. A
PERSON WHO PAID INTO MEDICARE
AND RECEIVES IT NOW I OPPOSE AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED YOU MAGGOTS.
YOU PROBABLY PICKED UP ON THE
FACT THAT I'M STILL ANDREA AND
WE'RE JUST GETTING STARTED AND
WE OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
OPEN THE BUILDING AND WE'RE
AGAINST ALL THE COMMUNISTS
COMING OUT OF THE- YOU'RE
WELCOME TO BE STE. WELL THE
MOTHER BEAR AND WE'RE DONE WITH
IT EXPECTED PLEASE THANK YOU.
SAY NO OTHER SPEAKERS AT THE
REMOTE STATION WERE MOVED TO
OPERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
TELEPHONE LINE AT THAT WOULD
LIKE TO. SPEAK ON THE ITEMS THAT
HAVE BEEN DESCRIBED THEY WERE
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE- ON
SUSPENSE. IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AT THE END OF THE ROW AT THIS
TIME. CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE IN HERE WILL GO TO
ONE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI ANY ECONOMICAL WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION PROUD CO
SPONSORS AND IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE IQ QUICK SILVA EIGHTY SIX
EIGHT ONE PROMINENT ON EIGHTY
SIX EIGHT SIX ARAMBULA THANK YOU
. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO FIVE
SEVEN FOUR. ONE BY TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
KITCHEN IN LONDON ON BEHALF OF
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDING COMMENT IN
REGARDS TO EIGHTY EIGHTY SEVEN
WE SUPPORT THE INTENTION OF THE
EFFORT AND LOOK FORWARD TO.
COUNTER RUSSIAN AFTER PART THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIDE ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CAREY MEMBERS TOLD ME OF POLICE
SHOCK CALLING IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION FOR THE FOLLOWING
BILL. EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE NINE FOUR. A. B.
ELEVEN NINETEEN EIGHTY TO NINETY
FIVE A. B. FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND
THEY'RE PROUDTO CO SPONSOR
EIGHTY SIX FIVE FIVE ALSO
CALLING TO SUPPORT EIGHTY FOUR
FIVE TWO BY LOS ANGELES CITY IT
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES CITY
ATTORNEY MIKE PIERCE OFFICE. AND
CALLING TO SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING
BILLS FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES SB THREE SIX FIVE A. B.
649-885-4893 FIVE AND ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
ALL IN SUPPORT OF AB. FOURTEEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY PLEASE
CALL. I NICOLE KERR THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF CALIFORNIA
YOU'RE ALREADY KILLING US BY
WITHHOLDING READILY AVAILABLE
CHEAP MEDICINE MY GABBER MACTAN
AND PARKING RUN DEATHLY FEAR WE
SHUDDER TO THINK WHAT YOU WOULD
DO WITH. MEDIATION AND POSITION
PLEASE. NEXT BIGGER THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE TWENTY ONE THREE
IS GLAD. YES MY NAME IS BARBARA
AND I. IS COMPLETELY OPPOSED AND
EIGHTY FOURTEEN HUNDRED IT IS
ACTUALLY COMING TO TAKE A
PROPOSAL TAKE UP. THANK YOU Y.
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS ONE THAT SADDAM I'M A GOOD
TRIAL CALENDAR FOR THIS VERY
REASON I OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED VEHEMENTLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
SIX FOUR. HI BELIEVES HOGAN WITH
HEALTH ACTIVE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE THIRTY THREE
AM AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE. THANK
YOU LINE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI CAN BE HOLIDAY
DISABLED AMERICANS. FORMER MMHM-
BOARD MEMBER OF GOVERNMENT JOINT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED.
THANK YOU LINE ONE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LAURA REGIMEN AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
CAL CARE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M ONE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS NICHOLAS
SACKETT SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
INTO PORT AB. FIVE FIVE EIGHT.
THANK YOU I'M FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JEFF
GREEN AND I AM- SOCIT RECTOR OF
ANYONE EQUITY COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST AND I AM SPEAKING IN
STRONG FAVOR OF AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU I WANT TO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT I LOVE
HOW ANYBODY THAT IT FOLLOWING
ALONG WITH WHAT YOU GUYS GET TO
STAY HERE MORE THAN THIRTY
SECONDS. RIGHT THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THIS IS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF MINE ONE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND ONE
DOLLAR EIGHT YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
. PERFECT MY NAME IS KAYLA
CURTAIN CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
VALLEY INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATIONS LIKE AT- AND WE
HAVE BY BILLS TO SPEAK ON IT
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY FIVE WE
SUPPORT IF AMENDED. EIGHTY ONE
OH ONE FOUR WE SUPPORT EIGHTY
FOURTEEN HUNDRED WE OPPOSE
EIGHTY ONE ONE ONE NINE WE
OPPOSED AND EIGHTY THREE SIX
FIVE WE SUPPORT. THANK YOU OF
MINE ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADDIE MONTHS IN ON
BEHALF OF THE AGRICULTURAL
ENERGY CONSUMERS WITH THE ASIAN
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOUR MIND ONE
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS RICHARD AND AS THE TUBBS
FIRE SURVIVOR AND THE CLAIMANT
IN THE FIRE VICTIMS TRUST I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
FORTY NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI DAN I GO
THROUGH CO CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE FOR THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WHICH REPRESENTS THREE
MILLION REGISTERED DEMOCRAT AND
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHICH
REPRESENTS TEN MILLION
DEMOCRATS. BOTH ORGANIZATIONS
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOUR MIND EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS MIGHT CAN ASKING
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
AB SIX FOUR SIX SUPPORT. THANK
YOU OF MINE ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RICHARD HARRIS
PRESIDENT OF FRANCISCO PUBLIC
GOLF ALLIANCE OPPOSE SB SIX
SEVEN TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE SIXTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JESSICA
TUNIS MORE MEMBER OF OUR
REVOLUTION NORTH BANK STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
HEALTHCARE AND A SURVIVOR OF THE
TUBBS FIRE. ONLY SUPPORT AB
TWELVE FORTY NINE GALLAGHER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO OUT.
HI MY NAME'S TODD YOU COMMON
REPRESENTING HEALTH FREEDOM
ACTIVISM CALIFORNIAN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY THIS
IS MARCELLA I AM AN RN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE FOURTEEN
HUNDRED. THANK YOU LINE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
ANTONIO SANCHEZ WITH IBEW LOCAL
ELEVEN IN LOS ANGELES I'M EXTEND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION. TO TWELVE
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU A
WIDE ONE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ERIN LEHANE ON
BEHALF OF THE HALF A MILLION
MEMBERS OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN. THANK THANK YOU RYAN
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
JEFF ON A ROCK HUMBOLDT DEL NORD
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
STAND WITH THE STATEBUILDING
TRADES AND VERY VERY STRONG
OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS CONNIE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
FOURTEEN HUNDRED IT'S OBVIOUS
THE STATE DOESN'T KNOW HOW ABOUT
HOW TO MANAGE ANYTHING. STOP
TAKEOVER OF OUR- THEY CAN EXPECT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE SIX
THREE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MAN RODRIGUEZ OF THE
AFT EDUCATION TRUST WEST YOU'D
EXPRESSIVE WORK FOR AB ONE OH
TWO BY PHONE NUMBER HOLDEN AB
TWO EIGHT EIGHT. BERMAN BONTA A.
B. ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN NUMBER.
THANK THANK YOU LINE ONE OH
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN. ONE
ZERO THREE. AT ONE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS MATT MILLER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE INDEPENDENT
NOTARIES AND WE ARE CALLING TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TEN NINETY
THREE RIMAU ON LANDOWNERS PUBLIC
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOUR
MIND SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SEVEN FOUR. WELL.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOHN I SHOULD
LOS ANGELES COUNTY HOSTAGE
CATION IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
FIVE TWO QUICK SILVA AND AB ONE
OH TO. HOLD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
A LINE ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS IAN AS
THEY CAN ARE REGISTERED NURSE
AND ON THE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION.
CALLING IN TO STRONGLY OPPOSE A.
B. FOURTEEN HUNDRED. THANK YOU I
WON SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO ONE ONE SEVEN EIGHT.
YOUR PEOPLE TOGETHER RIGHT ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF THE FOLLOWING
ASSEMBLY BILLS. FIFTY EIGHT TO
SEVENTEEN TO NINETY FIVE THREE
TWENTY ONE FOUR AWAIT OR EIGHTY
FIVE FIVE FIFTY TO SIX EIGHTY
ONE SEVEN FORTY EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR. 441-093-1011 SIXTY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF MINE ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SYDNEY
HOFF WHAT IS RESOLUTE AND ON
BEHALF OF THE ALL THE PORTABLE
FASTER CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE FOUR ZERO ZERO THANK YOU
. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS UERY ON THE
APPALACHIAN STATE TULANE
ASSOCIATION CALLING OPPOSITION
TO AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN MCCARTY
AND ALSO. THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE CALL HAS. YES HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ROBERT
JOHN I REPRESENT THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE
COALITION AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB FORTY HUNDRED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS TIED UP A GALLON OF
PROGRESSIVE ASIAN NETWORK FOR
ACTION CALLING IN FULL SUPPORT
OF STAVING PATIENTS MONEY AS
WELL AS BUSINESSES WITH SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT ONE OH SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I NEED TO DO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL COMMUNITY
HEALTH AGENCY PALCO CONCERT OF
AB SIXTY SIX POINT THE FOLLOWING
BELT AB THIRTEEN NINETEEN.
873-885-1980 SIX EGHTY ONE I'M
ALSO AT THE CALIFORNIA ACT THAT
COALITION IN THE ON. ZERO EIGHT
EIGHT NINE THREE THREE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE CALL AHEAD. KAREN
ROCKWELL OF SALINAS CALIFORNIA
CALLED IN SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA
GUARANTEED HEALTHCARE FOR ALL
ACT AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIDE ONE FORTY
THREE PLEASE CALL HAD. HELLO
THIS IS MITCHELL BATTLE WITH THE
DISCOUNTS LEVINE WORKERS WE
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MAC
COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS HERE TODAY
IN OPPOSITION AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU. BANK YOUR Y. ONE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS TIFFANY AND I'M
CALLING TO OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE
RIGHT ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JESSICA
MORAN OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
AT EIGHTY FOR A GREAT DEAL.
THANK YOU I WON THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALEX CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHRONIC
CARE COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB NINE THREE THREE. THANK
YOU I ONE THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND ONE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO OUT. YES MY NAME'S
QATARI QUITE YOU DVD FROM THE L.
L. C. BUILDING TRADES AND WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU LINE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS MELISSA GRACE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B. FOURTEEN HUNDRED
AND ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO AND
VOTE NO ON AB. FOURTEEN HUNDRED.
THANK YOU LINE ONE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MILLIONS OF
COLOGNE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIDE ONE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUILDING
GRIEVES ABOUT COM CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN ONE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
ROBERT CURTIS PRESIDENT OF THE
CITY OF SAMPOERNA DINO PUBLIC
RETIRED EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
WHO ALL STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE
FOUR ZERO ZERO SINGLE HEALTH
CARE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. THANK
YOU LINE TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS PATTY
HARVEY I AM A CO CHAIR OF THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY CHAPTERS OF
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
AND PHYSICIANS FOR A NATIONAL
HEALTH PROGRAM WE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT AB
FORTY. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY THIRTY
THREE. I CAN'T REMEMBER. THANK
YOU ALL SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
CHANGE OUR MEMBERS THIRTY TEN
MEDICARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU. NINE ONE
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SANTA DOUGLAS WHAT HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA CALLING FOR A. B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED IN SUPPORT
CONTEMPT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I.
MORE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. NEWS MIKE REALLY WITH THAT
YOUR COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTER
KNOWLEDGE TRADES WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU LINE TO ALL
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KATIE
LITTLE WITH THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU AND WE OPPOSE AB TWELVE
EIGHTY. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT PRE REQUIRED. HELLO
AGAIN KITCHEN A LIVING ON THE
AFTER THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY INSTRUCTORS AB TWO
EIGHT EIGHT I BONTA. THANK YOU
IDE ONE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
CHIMNEYS AND I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF PROJECT MATH LOS
ANGELES I'M ALSO AN ELECTED
MEMBER OF THE LAPD P. CENTRAL
COMMITTEE AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED.
THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE CALL AT. YES DOCTOR BILL
HONIG MEN'S MURDERS THE
PHYSICIAN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE RIGHT TO THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AT. YES I'M THE CALL
YOUNG WITH PLASTER COUNTY MOM
FOR LIBERTY AND STRONG
OPPOSITION AT EIGHTY FOURTEEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO OR EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
WILLIAM GOOD DOLLARS I'M WITH
THIS ACCOUNT SIXTEEN PAIRS NOW
LIKE TRADES AND WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
WON ALL THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE ZERO THREE. TWO
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT JUST DEMAND ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC ADVOCATE
CALLING INTO COURT AT EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT BONTA AND AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY AND COMBINE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS WERE
NOT DONE- CALIFORNIA
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATES. I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED. TO EIGHTEEN
FOURTEEN HUNDRED. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TO EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JEETENDRA
HARLAN PARK CALLING ON BEHALF OF
GROUND GAME LOS ANGELES AND
SUNRISE MOVEMENT LOS ANGELES. AS
WELL AS THE ASSEMBLY ELECTED
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE
PEOPLE ACTION LATE FOURTEEN
MEMBERS OF US AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED. THANK YOU I'M ONE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOINT
COMMITTEE WEAPONS ON
CALIFORNIA'S BY CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE AND OPPOSITION- TWO
EIGHT B. TWELVE EIGHTEEN. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TO TWENTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ROBERT COOKING FOR THE HEALTH
CARE FOR AFFECTING THE BALLOT
CHAPTER STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND AB FIFTEEN
OH TWO. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS CLIPPER KASTNER
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
AMERICANS FOR DEMOCRATIC ACTION
IT SAID OF NATIONAL SMART
ORGANIZATION FOUNDED BY ELEANOR
ROOSEVELT AND WE ARE URGING
STRONG SUPPORT FOR EIGHT B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED. CAL CARE ACT.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS SHERIN REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT TO THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH HI
MY NAME IS BETTY DO NOT POTO I'M
CALLING FOR ASK THEM FOR S. P.
PROJECT AND FEEL THE BURN SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY WE ATE WE
APPROVE OF AB FORKING ON GETTING
THE FINAL VOTE IT UP. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND ONE ZERO
THREE. BY TWO FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
RANDALL NAY NUMBER DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES WE STAND WITH THE
BILLING TRAIN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- OPERATOR
OF THAT- CONCLUDES THE REGULAR
ORDER PORTION OF OUR HEARING-
I'D LIKE TO IF I COULD NOW TURN
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE OF FIRST OF
ALL THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND YOUR- BEING ABLE TO
MAKE OUR WAY THROUGH THE REGULAR
ORDER- THE SERGEANTS WILL PASS
OUT OF THE- COPY OF THE SUSPENSE
AGENDA FOR EACH COMMITTEE MEMBER
BEFORE I START WITH THE SEVENTY
SIX BILLS ON SUSPENSE FILE. I
LIKE TO THINK THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE
REPUBLICAN FISCAL STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK THESE ARE NOT
EASY MEETINGS TO ORGANIZE AND
PUT TOGETHER. SO I THANK THEM
FOR THAT. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE STAFF OF THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANT'S
OFFICE THE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY PERSONNEL AND THE
MANY OTHERS WHO HELPED ENSURE
THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS. THANK
YOU. I ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY
VOICE HERE FOR HIS COOPERATION
AND SUPPORT MISTER BIGELOW THANK
YOU- WITH THAT- IF EVERYONE HAS
THE- THE SUSPENSE OF PILOT
GENDER. THEN WE WILL- BEGAN.
OKAY OKAY. SO OUR FIRST BILL HIS
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX OH SEVEN
ARAMBULA BLOOD SCREENING TAX
EXEMPTION HOLDING COMMITTEE
MOVED TO BELL. WE HAVE TO. NOT A
WHOLE NINETY WERE YEAH NO
PROBLEM. OKAY ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
SIX AROUND COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN POWER K.
HAND GENDER BASED PRICE
DISCRIMINATION THIS IS A DO PASS
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION MOVED TO
BELL IS THERE A SECOND. TO
SECOND IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED THE BILL GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. WE'LL JUST REPLACE
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
SUBSTITUTE THE MOTION AND SECOND
FOR ALL DO PASS OR DO PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS ON THE REST OF
THE SUSPENSE FILE. AB SIX SIX
ONE BENNETT BY RECYCLE CAMPAIGN
MODIFICATIONS DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO MODIFY PAPER AND
PAPER PRODUCTS AND RECYCLED
GLASS PROVISIONS AND TO MAKE
OTHER TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT
IS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWELVE OH SIX BENNETT LAND TRUST
WELFARE EXEMPTION DO PASSES
AMENDED TO REQUIRE CLAIMANTS TO
SUBMIT AN AFFIDAVIT. REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
NINE BENNETT BY CLEAN CALIFORNIA
ACT DO PASSED OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. AB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT BONTA
SCHOLARSHIP DISPLACEMENT DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO CHANGE
AUTHOR TO CALDERON AND TO ENSURE
THAT INSTITUTIONS CAN NOT REDUCE
INSTITUTIONAL AID TO ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS DUE TO PRIVATE
SCHOLARSHIPS UNLESS THE STUDENTS
GIVE AID EXCEEDS THE STUDENTS
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. HEY IT'S
NOT ON A ROLL CALL. BURKE AND
REPUBLICANS ARE DOING. DO PASSED
YEAH. AB THIRTY TWENTY EIGHT
BRIAN. REENTRY HOUSING AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT HOLDING
COMMITTEE ALTHOUGH I'M HOLDING
THIS BILL TODAY I RECOGNIZE THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT POLICY ISSUE
I HAVE ENCOURAGED THE AUTHOR TO
INTRODUCE A NEW UPDATED BILL IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
AND COMPLIMENT HIS STATE BUDGET
REQUEST I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING HIS EFFORT AND TO
REVISITING THIS ISSUE. IN THE
COMING YEAR. AB THREE TWENTY
EIGHT I'M SORRY WE DID THAT. AB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX OF ARTISTS
LOCAL AND MORE TAX CREDIT HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB TWELVE- TO SERVE
ON TO THIS LOCAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN CERVANTES
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION DO PASS. ON B. ROLL
CALL. AB FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
CERVANTES HIGHER EDUCATION
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELORS DO
PASS OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL. AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT CERVANTES
EMERGENCY PLAN MEDICAL EQUIPMENT
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB TWO FOUR
THREE CHOI MEDICAL EXPENSES TAX
DEDUCTION HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
TWO FORTY NINE CHOI RESEARCH TAX
CREDIT HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
THREE TWENTY FOUR CHOI ATTIC
VENT TAX CREDIT HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB EIGHT TWENTY IN
COOLEY INTEREST INCOME TAX
EXCLUSION HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
NINE THIRTY THREE DALY ARC
STRUCK REBATES OLDEN COMMITTEE
. AB TWO TWO SEVEN DAVIES
GOVERNOR APPOINTMENTS HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB FOUR FIFTY TWO
FRIEDMAN GUN NOTIFICATIONS DO
PASS OUT ON OUR A ROLL CALL. AB
TWELVE FORTY NINE GALLAGHER
WILDFIRE SO MANY THINGS INCOME
EXCLUSION DO PASSES AMENDED TO
CLARIFY DEFINITION OF QUALIFIED
TAXPAYER OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
JUSTIN CAN WE TAKE A STEP BACK
ON FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
CERVANTES. IT WAS ALL. IT'S A DO
ON A- THE EMAIL OKAY ALL. THIS
IS. THIRTY FOUR SIX SEVEN DID
YOU GET THE TERROR OKAY OKAY IF
WE COULD WILL GO BACK TO AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN CERVANTES
HIGHER EDUCATION SEXUAL ASSAULT
COUNSELORS TO PASS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. AB SIX SEVENTY TWO GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA GOLF COURSE
CONVERSIONS HOLDEN COMMITTEE. A.
B. CHANNEL ONE CRISTINA GARCIA
SEQUIN MITIGATION AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES DO
PASSED OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE CRISTINA
GARCIA DIET PILLS TO PASS OUT ON
THE B. ROLL CALL. AB NINETY
THREE EDUARDO GARCIA PANDEMIC
CRAP AND RESPONSE HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB NINE FORTY THREE
EDUARDO GARCIA G. R. F. FUNDING
PROGRAMS HOLDING COMMITTEE. SB
ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE GIPSON
CHEMICAL AGENTS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO NARROW THE PRO
PROHIBITION THE ONLY PERSONS
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN AND
STRIKE THE STAFF RATIO THAT'S
OUT ON A. B. LOCAL. SB TWO FORTY
FIVE GONZALEZ ABORTION COST
SHARING DO PASS. I'M SORRY
PEOPLE IT HE WILL CALL THE ROLL
CALL. AB ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE
GRAYSON CONSOLIDATION. OKAY
LET'S SEE AB ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE
GRAYSON CONSOLIDATION OF HOUSING
FINANCE PROGRAMS. HOLDEN
COMMITTEE CALDERON OKAY. AB ONE
OH TWO HOLDEN DUAL ENROLLMENT TO
PASS A ROLL CALL. AB SIX SEVENTY
SIX HOLDEN FRANCHISES DO PASS
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB FOUR
ELEVEN IRWIN VETERANS HOUSING
BOND TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CHANGE THE BALLOT YEAR TO TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING THAT'S OUT ON.
REPUBLICANS ARE VOTING. AB FIVE
EIGHTY ONE IRWIN CYBERSECURITY
DO PASSED OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN IRWIN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IT'S A
TUTORING DO PASS REPUBLICANS
SUPPORTING OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TEN NINETY THREE JONES SAWYER
REMOTE ONLINE NOTARIES DO PASS
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
THIRTY KALRA OUTDOOR ACCESS TO
NATURE TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
DELETE THE HUMAN RIGHTS AND
PROVIDE ALL STATE AGENCIES
IMPLEMENTING THIS BILL SHOULD DO
SO IN A MANNER CONSISTENT WITH
THEIR MISSION AND IN A MANNER
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC. AND THAT
IS OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL. SB
SIX FIFTY FIVE KARA CLEAR ACT DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO ACCEPT
AUTHOR AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
DEFINITIONS THAT'S ALL GOING TO
BE ROLL CALL. AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED KALRA SINGLE PAYER
HEALTHCARE DO PASSES AMENDED.
AMENDED TO MAKE IMPLEMENTATION.
CONTINGENT ON A STATUE TO CREATE
REVENUE MECHANISMS TO FUND CALC
HERE A FISCAL REPORT ON WHETHER
CAL CARE CAN BE IMPLEMENTED AND
FURTHER APPROVAL BY THE
LEGISLATURE- THAT IS OUT ON THE
B. ROLL CALL WITH WEBER NOT
VOTING. AB FORTINO SIX LACKEY
STUN GUNS TO PASS. ON A ROLL
CALL. AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE
LEVINE INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
REVIEW DO PASS A ROLL CALL. SB
SIX THIRTY FIVE LOW CALIFORNIA
EDUCATIONAL FACILITIES AUTHORITY
HOLDING COMMITTEE. SB SIX FORTY
SIX LOW EXPUNGE CONVICTIONS DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE
FEE PROVISIONS. A. B. AND THAT
IS OUT ON A NO REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB TEN FORTY FIVE LOW
BONE MARROW DONOR REGISTRY
HOLDING COMMITTEE. A. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTEEN AT LOW HIGHER EDUCATION
ENDOWMENT FUNDS HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB EIGHT OH FIVE
MAIENSCHEIN PP REPORT HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB NINE THIRTY FIVE
MAIENSCHEIN MENTAL HEALTH ECON
SOLD HOLDEN COMMITTEE A. B.
SEVEN OH FOUR MAYES STUDENT LOAN
TAX DEDUCTIONS HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
AB FIVE NINETY FOUR MCCARTY LAW
ENFORCEMENT POLICIES HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TEN FOURTEEN
MCCARTY CANNABIS DELIVERY TO
PASS AS AMENDED AMENDMENTS
CHANGE THE AMOUNT OF CANNABIS
THAT CAN BE TRANSPORTED ENHANCE
TRACKING TO INCLUDE DELIVERY AND
REMOVE CHP. AND THE REPUBLICANS
ARE NOT VOTING. WITH ITSELF. I
AB TWELVE EIGHTEEN- MCCARTY-
DESERVES TO PASS THE WITH
REPUBLICANS IT'S ON A B. ROLL
CALL- WITH CALDERON NOT GOOD. AB
TWELVE THIRTY TWO MCCARTY
NONRESIDENT TUITION WAIVER DO
PASSED OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB
FIFTY NO TUMOR SEARCHING NURSING
HOME LICENSING DO PASS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL. AB FIVE FIVE EIGHT
AND IS THERE ANY SPECIAL SCHOOL
MEALS DO PASS REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING THERE'S OPPOSITION. AND
QUIRK NOT VOTING- THERE'S
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
CONCERNING THE DEFINITION OF
PLANT BASED FOOD AND WHETHER THE
BILL COULD RESULT IN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS PURCHASING PLANT BASED
PRODUCTS THAT ARE MANUFACTURED
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO
URGE THE AUTHOR TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO RESOLVE THIS ISSUE
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD. AB
FORTY FIVE GRAND CRIME REPORTING
DO PASSED. OUT ON A RECALL. AB
THREE FIVE THREE O'DONNELL WILL
TRUST FUND DO PASSED OUT ON OVER
A ROLL CALL. AB THREE SIX FIVE
OH DONALD DRAYAGE TRUCK TAX
EXEMPTION HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
FOUR OH EIGHT QUICK SILVA
HOMELESS STUDENTS DO PASSED OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. AB FIVE FIVE TWO
QUICK SILVA SCHOOL BASED MENTAL
HEALTH DO PASSES AMENDED
AMENDMENTS ARE MAINLY CLEAR
FINDING TECHNICAL THAT'S WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT QUICK SILVA
LOW INCOME HOUSE HOUSING TAX
CREDIT DO PASSES A MINUTE TO
ALIGN WITH PREVIOUS BUDGET
ACTIONS REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
AB SIX EIGHTY ONE RAMOS DOJ
REPORTING MENTAL HEALTH HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWO TWO EIGHT
RODRIGUEZ FIRE ARMS DEALERS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ACCEPT AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION AND REQUIRE 30%
250% INSPECTION RATING.
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE RODRIGUEZ
FACILITY OBLIGATION RESET DO
PASS THAT'S NOT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB FIFTY EIGHT SALAS SUICIDE
PREVENTION DO PASSED THAT'S OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWO NINETY
FOUR SANTIAGO TOW STORAGE
PERMITTING HOLDING COMMITTEE.
LET ME ALSO SAY ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL PEOPLE HAVE
THEIR CARS TOWED AND STORED TO
STORE DUE TO NEED BETTER
PROTECTION FROM UNSCRUPULOUS
ACTORS HOWEVER THERE ARE STILL
TOO MANY UNRESOLVED ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL. I
HOPE THE AUTHOR WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THE ISSUE AND BRING A
SIMILAR BILL BACK FOR THE
LEGISLATURE THIS SPRING. AB
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN SANTIAGO VALID
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION DO PASSED
OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL. SIXTY
NO SEVENTEEN BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
TAKE BACK STUDY DO PASSED. OUT
ON THE B. ROLL CALL AB TWELVE
FORTY TEEING INDOOR AIR
POLLUTION STUDY UPDATE DO PASSED
AS AMENDED TO MOVE. THE DUE DATE
FROM JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB TWELVE SEVENTEEN
VILLAGERS SCHOOL SUPPLIES TAX
HOLIDAY HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
THREE TWENTY ONE GO THERE IS
TALC HERE IN ROMAN PRIORITY DO
PASSED OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB
TWO FIFTY A BILL APPROVED TO
DRAW. LOW BARRIER SHELTER
SHELTERS HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
THREE ELEVEN WARD GUN SHOWS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ACCEPT AUTHOR
IMMENSE TO LIMIT THE BILL TO THE
DEL MAR FAIRGROUNDS THAT'S OUT
ON THE B. ROLL CALL. AND AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY TWO- COMMITTEE
ON JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
THE ECONOMY NEW MARKETS TAX
CREDIT HOLDING COMMITTEE. THE
CONCLUDES. WITH OKAY I'M SORRY
WHAT MISTER. THE HOBBIT THANK
GOD IT WE HAVE ONE MORE ONE MORE
MORE. THIS IS- AB NINETY FIVE
LOW. HOLDEN COMMITTEE. SO THAT
CONCLUDES THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SUSPENSE FILE THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.